안녕하십니까. 재미턴 여러분. 일부
아니죠? 죄송합니다.네
7월 14일 화요일 7시
30분입니다. 일부 시작하겠습니다.
전일 한국 시장 미국 시장 상당히 더
안 좋았던 거 같은데요. 중국 시장은
어떻게 마감됐는지 저희 왕부장과 함께
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 충구 시전도 좀 그렇게 좋지
않고요. 아시아 증시 동화 그리고
대형 FO 현장 이슈 이후로 상수
어제는 매너스 2%로 빠졌어요.
상선의 지수는 매너스 염증 9%
빠졌고 증시 거대가면 2.8조 수준
나왔습니다. 그 대형 피오는 여기서
창시 매물리입니다. 제 창시 매물리
어제는 받은 그 내부 자존 분위기가
2분 달 27일 상정이 예정입니다.음
>> 확정된 거예요? 어 뭐 내부 자료
보면 그렇게 나왔습니다.네 공료네
>> 업종별 좀 부시면 에너지 유디 금융동
검증이 강세하고 발면은 IT 부동산
소재 업정이 약세가 되었습니다. 어
구제 요가 다시 상승으로 에너지
관련주 강세 보였고요. 배터 최원는
어 4% 올라고 신호펜는 2.5%
청구 신호하는 4% 산시적는 4.5%
라왔어요. 배당 방어주인 유틸리티
관련주 어제도 돌아왔습니다. 정강
정료는 1.4% 4% 환능 수정은
2% 고추는 1.8% 올라왔어요. 어
소비자 관련주 또 이틀 연소
상승했습니다. 위주마는 0.5%
주시는 0.5% % 있는 1.5%
왔어요. 이번기 허실적 기대감으로
2차 청지 대형주만 돌아왔습니다.
C티어는 어제 3% 가이 올라왔어요.
그리고 2분기 가정 수주 데이터
허조에 대한 기대함으로 가정 관련주에
상승했습니다. 메디 클럽는 1.8%
거리 가전는 1.2% 올라왔습니다.
아마 메디클럽 거리 가정 다 대표적인
방어 그 겁에다온 방어주잖아요.
그래서 어제는이 관영주들이 다
올라왔습니다. 음
>> 한편은 지난주 금일 많이 빠졌던 그
광동신 관련주도 리소프 반등
나왔어요. 중제부천는 1.3%
상승세가
나왔습니다. 뭐 반면 이해 반주어
어제는 다 빠졌습니다. 공업연은 매너
4.8% 스승인테크 대표적인 그
CCR 권 관련주이고요. 어제 10%
한가 그리고 성난 정류는 그냥
-7.5% 호전 중시는 -3.7%
7% 3 정작 - 12%도 빠졌어요.
신념물 구체 금리는 0.5bp
상승했습니다. 연물 구체 금리 너스
0.3b 하라고 유양화 확률는
0.08% 8% 서포 전화되었습니다.
>> 음. 감사합니다. 어,
이란과 미국이 처음 전쟁할 때를
비교해 보면 어, 한국도 그렇고
미국도 그렇고 어, 반도체, IT
이런 종목들 업종은 상당히 안 좋았고
당연히 어 유가와 관련되 있는
커뮤니티 관련주들 상당히 좋고 뭐
이런 특징들이 좀 있었는데 중국도 뭐
크게 다르지 않을 거라고 생각합니다.
어, 52 신고가를 그럼에도 불구하고
낸 종목들 제가 쭉 보다 보니까 제약
두 개는 제약이겠지. 네. 알겠어요.
근데 이제 그 밑에부터 뭐 땡땡 전자
이런 것도 있긴 한데 우리 왕부장
아시는 종목이면 좀 간단하게 어떤
업종인지 좀 말씀 좀 부탁드릴 수
있을까요?
>> 아 거의 없습니다. 정말
>> 아니면 시간에 너무나 저
>> 이게 위안가 아니라 원이죠.
>> 네. 오저원은 그 거의 그
소형주이고요.
>> 네. 실적 안 나오는 서현주 때문에
그래서 저도음
>> 그러네요. 이게 지금 단위가 10억
원도 아니고 원이기 때문에 여기 지금
표시된 것 중에 가장 큰 소연 제약
소연 신약도 5조 3,억 원 정도밖에
안 되니까
>> 상대적으로 상당히 스몰캡이어서 저희가
어
>> 잘 안 보는 예 그런 종목들일 수
있겠습니다. 그리고 왼편에 좀 보면
그 BOE부터 쭉 이제 자주 언급해
주시는 개 정도 종목이 리스트가 되어
있는데
>> 어 BOE 같은 경우에는 연초 이후에
어 전일 낙폭을 빼면 70% 이상
올랐다가 지금요 정도 낙폭이 있는 거
같고맞
>> 윤기 실리콘은 뭐 실리콘
>> 어 최근에 계속해서 좀 안 좋은 거
같고 중국 면세 이거는 어 중국의
아웃바운드 여행객 또는 인바운드
여행객 어디가
>> 아웃바운드 아웃바운드 훨씬 더 용을
컸다고 그렇게 생각할 수 있습니다.음
>> 여행 많이 가지 않아요?
>> 아 왜냐면 그 옛날에 코로나씩 그때
중구 사람이 그 해외로 나갈 수
없잖아요. 그래서 해난 면세점 중국
면세전 막 했나 거기서
>> 그쪽으로 가서는 쇼핑 많이 하고
그래서 그때는 실전는 대봐놨어요.
그다면 그 코로나 이후에 사람이
해외로 자비적으로 나갈 수 있잖아요.
>> 네. 지금이 사람이 대충들 뭐 한국,
동남마럽고 가고 있어요. 상대적으로
피해가 받고 있어요.
>> 음.
>> 예를 들어 해당 그 수피자가
>> 명 뭐 관련 가서 쇼핑할 수 있어요.
그래서 이제는 선택시가 많아졌어요.
네. 예를 들어서 군에 와서
>> 뭐 여기서 로데 면세 아니면 신화
호텔 면세 그 가면 쇼핑할 수
있잖아요.
>> 중국 예. 중국 내 내륙 관광보다
>> 네. 해외 건강이 많아지면 안
좋아지는 거 맞시면 됩니다.
>> 그럼 구조적으로 계속 그럴 거 같은데
부가 쌓일수록 해외 많이 가지
않겠습니까?
>> 예, 맞아요. 구조적으로 문제가 생길
수 있습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 그리고 여기 쭉 이제
보여 주시는 종목 중에
>> 어 보니까 밑에 이슈 종목 이제 오늘
10센트 준비는데
>> 지난주가 지지난 중인가 너무 많이
하락해 있다고 이제 언급해 주셨던
기억이다요.
>> 네. 여기 지금 어 위에
왼쪽에부터 항서 지하까지 그리고
가운데 줄에 10텐센트부터
센츠차이나까지 또 그렇게 좀 눈에
띄는 곡이 있으대요.
>> 아 이건 좀 너무 과한데
>> 그 시험이 지금 비슷하게 생각하고
있고
>> 다른 거는 아직도 뭐 티가 나는 거는
없다고 생각할 수 있습니다. 네
>> 알겠습니다. 어 불확실한데 말씀하시면
히트 레이쇼가 낮아지니까 확실할 때만
말씀을 좀 들어 보도록 하고 10센트
넘어가 보겠습니다.네 승전는 지금
시가중에 8배 정도 되고요. 포드
피을 12배가지 내려왔습니다.
그래서이 실적 실적 발벽 전에 그 관
리퍼드 하나 나왔습니다.
>> 1분기 매출는 동의 증가 수익 있는
동일 대비 5% 증가 예상입니다.
대충 시장서 보화 수준 나올 수
가능성 중이고요. P뉴얼 37%로
동기 대비 1% 하라. MP 마진는
33% 1.1% 분영 하라 예상이다.
>> 저 사우부 보시면이 부가 가치 사업부
매출했는 독일비 7% 증가
예상입니다.이
>> 종에 보면은 중국 군대 개인 매출는
동일대비 12% 증가 해외 매출는
동일 대비 9% 증가입니다. SNS는
관련 매출에는 또 거의 동기대비 풀
수준을 유지하고 있고요.
관거 사업부 매출는 동일대비 17%
정도 예상 하고 있습니다. 쇼폼 그
플랫폼 관거 매출는 동일대비 32%
증가하고요. 약간 지금 변화가 생기고
있습니다.
>> 금면동 서비스 차업부 매출는 동의
증가 예상하지만 기업 서비스 매출는
동의 증가 예상합니다. 1번개이 사업
부분이 대충는 동의 증가하고요.
그래서 2번에도 가속화되고 있는
상황입니다. 지금이 호산을 만든 의의
모델은 몇 개 정도 있는데요. 월
사용자수로 2천만 명 정도까했어요.
핵심 좀 보면은 1분기 케페스는
9억에 나왔어요. 동의는 125%
정도 증가했어요.
>> 음. 컨센서스 기준으로 2번개는
캠페스 투자는 대충 64억 정도
잡았어요. 아침에 좀 분위가 동의
238% 급정 예상입니다.
그래서 고성 증거 리포트 보면은 코어
사업부 승장 안정 그리고 투자 화대
등으로 원래 내년 내 훈년 2s는
각가 30 외한 32 외한 33
출전되었고 이중 내년 내년 EPS는
각가 6.1% 1% 5.7% 하
조전했어요. 음.
>> 타게 게임 사업는 피아는 15배
정도. 관거 사업는 20배. SNS
사업부는 16배. 금융동 사업 16배
PR를 적용해서 TP는 64달로
제시했어요. 지정 대비는 4.8%
정도 하지만 어제 종가 대비 40%
나오셨어요.
>> 네.어요 어,요 세부 내용들을 말씀해
주시니까 저희가 올해 얼마 전에
나누었던 대화가 기억이 나요.
장이센트
시가 총액이나 밸루에이션이 너무 많이
떨어져 있다는 말씀을 해 주시면서
제가 이유가 뭐예요? 그랬더니 여러
가지 이유가 있지만 투자에 대한
부담이 있는 거 같다. 그런 얘기를
해 주셨어요.
>> 여기 쭉 보니까 제가 잘 모르지만
저희가 PQC 분석이라고 할 때
>> 뭐 PQC 이런 것들은 그냥 원래
10센트가 하던 정도 대로 지금
나오고 있다고 봐도 되는 겁니까?
어네 맞아요. 그렇게 보셔도 되고요.
왜냐면이 등센트 이제 뭐 형은 할 수
있는 거는 되게 많고요. 왜냐면 지금
트센트는 가지고 있는 사용자는 14명
정도 되고요. 우리 위치에 다 쓰고
있어요. 얘도 카카오 저는 다 쓰고
있잖네요.
>> 아직도 외체는 A화는 되지 못했어요.
A젠트. 그러면이 부분은 잘되면은
훨씬 예전보다는 많이 변화가 생길 수
있다고 생각할 수 있어요. 다만 이거
어떻게 하는지 아직도 모르는 상황이고
그리고 캐투자 많이 해야 되고요.이
회자가 잘하는 거 있어요.
>> 이거는 돈 버는 그 포인트 나오면
그때 부도를 시작해요. 투자. 음.
>> 그러면 부이지 않으면 투자하지
않아요.
>> 아.
>> 네.
>> 아, 그니까 뭔가 선투자하고
>> 만드는게 아니라
>> 네.
>> 보이면
>> 맞아요.
>> 동시 투자.
>> 맞아요. 맞아요. 그렇게 보시면
되고요. 그래서 과거는이 칼패스
투자는 대충 매출에 10%는 좀
잡았어요. 2분기 칼패스 좀 봅시는
640억이 좀 나오잖아요. 그러면
이번기 매출에는 2012억이 좀
되네.
>> 그러면 이거는 30% 차지하고
있어요. 매출에 전 30% 차지하고
있으니까. 그래서 매우 그 공교적으로
하고 있는
>> 느낌이 KX를 10%대 정도 하다가
매출액이 30% 대를 한다는 뜻은
무언가 기회를 보고 투자를 한다는
뜻인데 어 물론 이제센트가 현명하게
잘 투자를 해서 미래의 매출과
수익으로 돌아올 거라고 믿지만 그
사이에를 기다리고 싶어 하지 않는
투자자들이 있기 때문에 밸류에이션이
떨어지는 건데
>> 맞아요
>> 어 저희가 미국의 하이퍼스케일러들 볼
때 지금 막 투자를 하다 보면
>> 어 두 개에서 세 개 정도의 승자가
가려지지 않겠냐라고 기대를 하고
있는데요.
>> 그 두 개에서 세 개 정도의 승자가
아마 현금 흐름으로 지금의 투자를
돌려받을 수 있는 시간이
담장은 아닐 것 같다.
>> 네. 적어도 수년 뒤 것 같다. 이제
그런 예상이 되면서 그런 기업들이
지금 주가가 KFX 보담 때문에 안
좋은데
>> 어 텐센트도 만약에 지금 이렇게
공격적으로 하는 투자가 어 매출이나
수익으로 돌려받을 수 있는 기간이
내년 후년이 아니라 조금 더 먼
미래라면 그리고 투자를 줄이지
않는다면 주가의 반등은 뭐 이렇게
너무 낙폭이 과대하면 조금 오르는
정도 기대를 해 봐야 될까요?
>> 네. 네. 그렇게 생각하시면 됩니다.
>> 음. 그리고이 회사가음
미국 이런 회사들이 그 뭔가요
고객을 많이 뭐 사용하고 있잖아요.
이렇 우리 그 구글 있잖아요. 그냥
계속 월 이용료를 내고 있잖아요.
충분히 이런 회사들이 이제 무료로
시작해요. 일단 그 시전 MS는 잡고
그다음에는 마지막 단계는 가격은 뭐가
ASP 인사하든지 아니면 요화하든지
그래서 이게 실적으로 기준을 하면은
되게 미국 기업단 아마 형 뭐 2년
1 2년 정도 디레이 될 수 있어요.
다만 그 전기적으로 관용만 하면은
나쁘지 않다고 생각해.
>> 음. 네. 여기서 말한 어 하양
조정했음에도 불구하고 업사이드 40%
나온다는 거는 궁극적으로 사업 모델의
어떤
>> 리더로서의 지위는 잃지 않을 거고
수익화는 될 거다라는 기대감들이 좀
있는 목표 주가이지 싶습니다.
>> 네.
>> 알겠습니다.
오늘 지난주 왕부장님이 말씀해
주셨는데 조금 더 자세한 데이터를
가지고 말씀 나눠 봤습니다. 전일
미국 시장으로 넘어가겠습니다. 창민
프로 부탁드립니다.
>> 네. 전일 미국 시험
말씀드리겠습니다. 월요일 미국 증시는
미국과 이란의 충돌 격화로 유가가
급등하고 한국발 반도체 매도세까지
전이 되면서 하락하는 모습
보여줬습니다. 시장 전반을 살펴본 뒤
오늘은 밀란 갈등 제조화에 따른 유가
급등 한국 반도체 세로니 미국
시정으로 번진 구조 그리고 서상 최대
매출을 확인한 TSMC까지 세 가지
정리해 드리도록 하겠습니다. 우선
미국 주요 지수 먼저 보겠습니다.
SMP 500은 0.79% 79%
하락한 7,15 아 7,515포인트로
마감하며 이틀 연속 이어지는 상승
흐름이 끊겼습니다.
기술주 비중이 큰 나스닥은 1.55%
하락했고 다운은 0.2% 하락에
거쳤습니다. 어셀 2천도 0.8%대
8% 때 하락했습니다. 특히
필라델피아 반도체 지수가 4.78%
급락하며 주요 지수 중 낙폭이 가장
컸습니다. 지정학 리스크와 반도체
급락이 겹치면서 위험자 전반의 위험의
피신리가 자극용한 거였다고 볼 수
있겠습니다. 다음으로 우측의 SMP
업정별 보시겠습니다. 정부 기술 쪽이
2.1% 하락하며 지수를 좀 끌어내린
모습 보여주었고요. 커뮤니케이션과
산업제도 1% 안파 하락했습니다.
반면에 유틸리티가 0.7%
금융급 필수 소비자가 0.6 6%
오르는 등 방어 성격 업종은 오히려
상승 마감하여 시장에서 빠져나간
자감이 지수 밖으로 이탈하기보다는
업종간 이동한 모습이 아니었나
생각듭니다.
다음으로 금리와 유가 보시겠습니다.
미국체 10년물 금리가 약 5
OBP홀은 4.62% 기록했습니다.
그리고 WTI는 8.9% 급등한
베럴당 77.8달러 달러 브랜트는
83달러를 넘어서며 4월 이후 최대
상승폭을 기록했습니다. 트럼프
대통령이 후르무주 회협을 지나는이란
선박에 대한 봉쇄를 제기하고 폐업을
통과하는 다른 화물에도 요금을
부과하겠다고 말한 것이 유가 상승의
주 원인으로 보입니다. 그서
지난주까지는 유가가 안정돼서 시장
영향이 제한적이라고 말씀드렸는데
이번에는 호르무주 물동량 정상화
기대가 좀 꺾이면서 유가와 금리가
동반 반응했다는 점이 좀 다른
점이라고 말씀드리겠습니다.
유가발 인플레이션 우려에 더해서
러연준 이사가 물가 압력을 잡기 위해
금리를 올려야 할 수 있다고
발언했고요. 단기 금리 시장이 7월
인상 확률을 50% 수준까지
반영했다고 블룸버그에서 언급했습니다.
그리고 중간에 위치한 52주 신고가
직보가 있습니다. 어제 신고가를
기록한 종목은 유틸리티의 도미니언
에너지와 에디슨 인터내셔널 그리고
금융의 애플럭과 MNT뱅크 그리고
헬스케어 쪽에 CVS 헬스 그리고
산업제의 CXX와 브레인저 요러구
정류사 관레로 에너지였습니다.
유가급등에 직접 수혜를 받는 정류와
실적 안정성이 높은 방어 업종의
신고가가 좀 물린 모습 보이고요.
기술주에서 빠져나온 자금이 시장을
떠나지 않고 방어 에너지로 순환하고
있다는 앞서 말씀드린 업종 흐름과 좀
일치하는 그림입니다. 그래서 아래쪽
보시면 그 필스 소비저 섹터랑 에너지
섹터 쪽이 좀 강한 모습 보이는데요.
네. 월마트, PG, 코카 플라코스트
전반적으로 1%대 상승 유지하면서
하락하지 않은 제 마감한 모습
보여주었고요. 그리고 에너지 섹터
쪽에 X모빌, 셰브론 에너지,
옥시덴탈, EOG 쪽에서 4%에서
3% 정도 상승 마감하는 모습 보시면
앞서 말씀드린 흐름 전반적으로 보실
수 있다고 말씀드리겠습니다.
다음에 좌측에 에픽테크 및 주요 종목
보시겠습니다.
>> 음.
>> 애플이 0.6%, 6%
마이크로소프트가 1.5% 오른 등
대형 소프트웨어와 플랫폼은 상대적으로
좀 견조한 모습 보였습니다. 반면에
반도체는 전반적으로 급락하는 모습
보여줬는데요. 엔비디아가 3.5%
AMD가 4.2% 마이크론이 4.4%
인텔이 6.1% 하락했고요. 장비주도
좀 하락하는 모습 보여줬는데요.
ASML이 4% 그리고 어프라이드
머티리스가 4.5% 램리서치가
5.8% 하락한 모습 보였습니다.
그리고 랜드 관련주인 샌디스크가
12.6% 6% 정도를 좀 급락하는
모습 보여줬습니다.
그래서이 반도체 급락의 출발점은 이제
한국 시장이었다고 보고 있는데요.
어제 코스피가 SK 하이닉스가 좀
15.4% 급락하면서 장중 서킷
브레이커 발동됐고 삼성전자도
10.7% 7% 정도 내리며 지수가
거의 9% 가까이 하락됐습니다.
그래서 지난 금요일 나스닥 상장 후
그 SK 하이닉스 ADR이 13%
오르며 그 상장이란 좀 ADR
상장이란 재료가 소멸하자 월요일에
본주에 좀 차익실험 매물이 쏟아진
것이 원인으로 보입니다. 그
>> 여기에 두 종목이 그 삼성전자와 ST
하이닉스가 시가총액의 절반 이상을
차지하는 솔림 구조 그리고 신용자
정보가 높고 단일 정보 레버리지
ETF가 좀 리밸런싱이 일어나면서
낙폭이 과도하게 커졌다는 것이 시장의
평가입니다. 그래서이 매도세는 뉴욕
개장후 SK 하이닉스 ADR과 미국
반도체주 전반으로 번지는 모습
보여주었고요. 앞서 말씀드린 유가
급등과 금리 인상 우려 시장이 이미
위험 회피 쪽으로 기울어 있던 터라
충격이 좀 증폭된 모습 보여줬습니다.
>> 그리고 좀 1측에서는 AI 과도하게
확정된 것 아니에는 경계신까지 좀
자극하는 모습이 보였다고
언급했습니다.
다음으로 TSMC 매출 공식 정리해
드리겠습니다. TSMC 2분기 매출이
전년 대비 36% 증가한 약 400억
달러로 사상 최대를 기록했습니다.
시장 예장 예상치를 소폭 우돌았고요.
회사가 4월에 시장 가이던스 범위에도
부합했습니다. 특히 6월 한 달
매출이 전년 대비 68% 정도
급증하며 월간 기준으로도 역도
세대였습니다. 그래서 올해 3나후
물량이 이미 완판됐다는 분석도 나오고
있어서 AI 칩 수요는 좀 여전히
견조하다는 신호로 해석하고 있습니다.
그외 기 이슈 기업 이슈로는 메타가
루이지에나 데이터 센터 캠퍼스에
400억 달러를 추가 투자하기로
하였고요. 이에 따라이 캠퍼스 한
곳에 대한 총 투자액은 2,500억
달러 넘어서는 모습 보였고요.
추가적으로 인텔릭 AI 봄 대응을
위해서 아일랜드 공장 증설에 약
57억 달러 투입한다고 밝혔습니다.
그래서 이런 근호장에도 AI 인프라
투자 자체는 계속 이어지는 뉴스가
나오고 있습니다. 마지막으로 오늘 밤
일정입니다. 6월 CPI가 발표되는데
최근 휘발류 가격이 좀 하락하는 모습
보이고 있었잖아요. 그래서 2020년
팬데믹 이후 처음으로 전널드비 하락
예상되는데 다만 유가가 다시 좀
급등하고 있는 모습이 보이는만큼
시장이 좋은 숫자에 크게 반응하지
않을 수 있다는 좀 지적이 나오고
있습니다. 그리고이어서 수요일에는
PPI 발표가 이어지고요. 목요일에는
TSMC 상세 실적 발표가 예정되
있는데 매출은 이미 나온만큼 시장의
초점은 마진과 3분기 가이던스에
맞춰질 것으로 예상됩니다.
>> 음. 그래서 오늘 내용
정리드리겠습니다. 어제 시장은
푸르무주발 유가 급등과 인플레이션
그리고 금리 인상 우려가 좀
되살아났고요. 한국발 반도체 세럼이
미국 미국으로 전의되며 위험회피 식
식가 좀 지배한 하루였습니다. 다만
TSMC 매출과 빅테크의 투자
확대해서 AI 수요 자체는 견조하게
확인됐고요. 지금과 명단이 보여주듯
자금은 시장을 떠나기보다 방어주와
에너지로 이동하고 있습니다. 그래서
오늘밤 CPI와 워시 의장 증원이
6가 긴축 우려를 키울지 진정시킬지가
광고권이 되겠습니다. 이상입니다.
감사합니다. 말씀 주신 것처럼 쭉
보니까 육가, 금리, 환율 뭐 이런
것들 볼 때 주식 시장에는 아주 안
좋은 방향으로 이런 매크로 변수들이
다 움직여서 지수가 좋긴 좀 어려운데
말씀 주신 것처럼 필수 소비제 쪽이나
여기 에너지 쪽 에너지는 당연히 유가
때문에 큰 상승을 보였을 거고 필수
소비제 종목들 뭐 월마트, 코카콜라,
코스트코어, PNG 이런 것들이
소폭이지만 오르고 반도체 IT
중에서도 저희가 보통 정 퀄리티
스탁이라고 얘기하는 애플하고
마이크로소프트는 소폭이지만
올랐습니다. 그래서 시장의 컬러가
이렇게 좀 분명 분명했던 거 같다라는
생각이 들고 어 미국하고 일어나고
지난 3월에 처음 전쟁할 때
반도체주가 가장 이제
신경질적으로 반영을 했던 것으로
기억하는데 어 전일 한국 시장의 큰
낙폭도 반도체 피크론뿐이
아닌 요런 전쟁에 대한 영향이 좀
묻어져 있기를
하는 생각을 하면서 좀 맞춰 보도록
하겠습니다. 가상자산으로
넘어가겠습니다. 우리 준혁님 가상자산
어제 어땠습니까?
>> 네. 가장 시장 흐름 보시면
아시겠지만 흐름이 좋지 않습니다.
어, 우선 물론은 어, 전쟁에 대한
반응이 아예 없었다라고 막 말하기에는
가격이 벌써 어, 한 2,000불
정도 빠져 있으니까 어, 각 그
전쟁에 대한 하락폭도 분명히 반영되어
있다고 생각하지만 그 부분 전
제한적이다라고 계속해서 말씀을 드리고
생각을 하고요. 어, 어제는
스트레티지가 비트코인을 매수하지 않
그니까 매수 또는 매도하지 않았다라는
뉴스를 발표를 했습니다. 그래서
그거에 대한 우려가 다시 한번
추가적으로 하락하는 모습, 하락하는데
반영을 됐다 이렇게 어 보고 있고요.
어제 나 한국시장 낮시간대의
기준으로는 뭐 다양한 이슈가 있어서
빠졌겠지만 어 빅테크 기업들이
회사치를 발행하는데 유동성적으로 좀
문제가 있다. 이런 식의 뉴스도 같이
한번 나오게 되면서 어 그렇게
된다라면 유동성이 지금 IT 쪽에
있는 몰려 있는 것도 문제가 있는데
어 다른 쪽으로 유동성이 좀 돌지
않지 않나? 이런 식으로 아이디어가
조금 어 확산이 되었다라고 생각 보고
있고요. 어 계속해서 소프트웨어
회사들과 계속해서 주가를 동조해 가는
그런 모습들을 보여주고 있습니다.
그래서 어 그런 회사들의 주가가 안
좋을 때 같이 하는 같이 반응하는
모습을 보여주고 있는데 어제 IGB
같은 어 소프트웨어 ETF도 주가가
굉장히 안 좋았고요. 그래서 사모시장
이슈에서도 계속해서 어 환매가 많이
나오고 있고 그런 부분들 그리고 금리
인상이 나올 수 있기 때문에 그런
사모 시장에서 어 유동성이 조금
악화가 된다라고 하면 가장자 시장에서
똑같이가 그 유동성이 들어오지 않지
않나 어 이런 아이디어 때문에
가흐름이 복합적으로 좀 안 좋지
않았나 이렇게 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다. 오른쪽 비트코인 장기 차트
보시면 200주 이평선을 지금 이탈한
상태입니다. 그래서 어 62,400불
정도가 딱 그 200주 200주
2평선인데요. 그 선을 지금 이탈해서
기술적으로도 그렇게 좋은 상황은
아니다. 이렇게 말씀드릴 수가 있을
것 같습니다. 비트코인 퓨레드 인덱스
보시면 어 지금 공포 구간에
있는데요. 어 이건 후행적이기 때문에
그래서 극단적 공포 구간에 머무를
것으로 예상합니다. 어 오른쪽에
크립토 시장 컨센서스도 보시면 지금
굉장히 긍정적으로 보고 있는 것으로
보실 수 있을 것 같습니다. 최근에
어 규제적으로도 그렇고 크리토 시장
어 비트코인나 이더리움이 아니더라도
뭐 예측 시장이라든가 스테이블 코인
쪽에서 좀 좋은 뉴스들이 나와주고
있었는데 그런 부분들을 반영한
컨센서스가 아닐까 하는 생각을 하고
있고 어 크립토 시장 어 전체적으로
봤을 때는 어 되게 그 변화가 많이
일어나고 있기 때문에 그런 부분들을
좀 반영한게 컨센서스가 아닐까 이렇게
말씀드리셨을 것 같습니다. 그냥
크립토 가격만 보고 봤을 때는 이게
굉장히 쏠림이 심하기 때문에 어
이렇게 되는게 맞나 하는 생각이 전
개인적으로 들었는데 어쨌든 뭐
규제적인 부분이나 아니면 실제로이
사업적으로 변화하고 있는 모습을 봤을
때는 긍정적인 부분이 있는 건 맞다
이렇게 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다. 어 그래서 제가 어제
하락을 했던 부분이 어제 그 한국시간
아까 말씀드렸던 것처럼 낮시간
한국시간 한국 그 장 어 장 중시간
때에는 어 빅테크 기업들의 회사치에
관련된 어 그런 이슈들이 나오면 좀
하락했다라고 말씀을 드렸고 두 번째
어제 어 미국장이 열리기 직전부터는
어 마이클 세일러가 돌을 하나
던졌다라고 생각을 합니다. 그래서
주의 첫 번째 제목에 보시면 기행에
가까운 판단을 보여주고 있는 세일러다
이렇게 제가 적어 놨는데요. 지난 한
주 동안은 비트 어 스트레테지는
비트코인이 아닌 MSTR 보통주
그러니까 MSTR을 한 460년
어치를 매도를 했습니다. 그래서 현금
장고가 3빌리언 정도까지
채워졌었는데요. 첫부터 비트코인이
아닌이라고 써 놓은 이유는 어 최근에
지난주 지지난주부터 해서 비 그 M
스트레티지가 비트코인을 이제 팔아서
자금 조달을 좀 하게 하겠다. 주주들
같이 희석시키지 않고 어 이제 좀
다시 주가를 부양하고 우선주의 패깅을
다시 한번 어 회복하기 위해서
비트코인을 팔아서 어 자금 조달를
하겠다라는 식으로 어 프레임워크를
제시했었는데요. 어 그래서 이번 주에
당연하게도 비트코인을 팔거나 아니면
아무런 변화가 없겠구나에 조금 더
치중이 돼 있었는데 어 비트코인이
아닌 그 스트레티지 주가 희석이 되는
어 보통주를 팔게 되면서 이게 뭐
하는 거지 하는 생각을 어 되게
시장에서 많이 했던 것 같습니다. 어
그래서 회사가 제시한 보통주 또는
우선주 매입 프로그램 그리고
비트코인을 매 비트코인 매도를 통한
자금 조달 프로그램은 단 하나도
이루어지지 않았고요. 어 회사가 같이
프리미엄을 받아서 이게 MN라고 하는
지표를 계속해서 말하는데 그게 1
넘어갔을 때 어 1 넘어갔을 때
비트코인 매입을 위한 자금 조달할
때처럼 액션이 이루어질인 것에 대해서
다른 혼란스러운 상황입니다. 그래서
지금까지는 계속이 mna가 1 이상
갔을 때 어 원래는 한 1.2 이상
정도라고 말을 어 보통 하더라고요.
그래서 1.2 2 이상 정도에서 어
프리미엄 받아서 어 보통주를 팔고
그다음에 비트코인 매입하는 그런
구조로 이루어졌었는데 어제 같은
경우에는 프리미엄을 안 받을 안 받지
않았습니다. 디스카운트를 받진 받는
수준은 아니었고 MNAB가 1보다는
위에 있었지만 어 보통 원래 팔던
1.2 이상은 아니었거든요. 1.2
이상은 아니었는데 어쨌든 어 보통주를
팔면서 어 그걸 현금으로 채웠다라고
하는 발표에 좀 충격을 많이 받은 것
같습니다. 그래서 왼쪽에 있는 사진을
보시면 MSD 보통주를 어 팔게
되면서 또 이번 그 유통 주식 대비해
1.5% 5% 정도가 추가적으로
발행이 된 거니까 희석이 좀 그 정도
이루어졌다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
오른쪽에 사진 보시면 주식 재미
프로그램도 안 했고 어 비트코인 매도
안 했고 하면서 어 달러 장보만 한
3빌년 정도가 채워졌다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그래서 1년 동안 지금
배당과 이자를 내야 되는게 1.8빌년
8빌년 정도가 되니까 2년 정도
2년에 조금 못 미치는 현금을 지금
확보해 둔 상태다. 근데 시장에서
예상했던 거는 그리고 시장에서
긍정적으로 봤어야 되는 부분은
비트코인을 팔아서 그 현금 장고를
채우는 거였는데 그게 아니라 주주들이
희석이 되는 어 MSTR 보통주를
팔아서 그 현금을 마련했다는 것이
시장이 굉장히 큰 악재였고 MSTR
자체에도 굉장히 악재였던 거
같습니다. 이게 여기기수 추가적으로
한 번에 더 나가게 된다라고 하면
세일러는 프레임워크를 제시하면서
1빌년, 1빌년, 1.25빌년
그러니까 총 한 3.25빌년 정도의
비트코인을 매도를 하겠다라는
프레임크를 제시를 했습니다. 그러면
어 사 투자자들 입장에서는 특히 뭐
비트코인 투자하는 사람도 있을 거고
MSTR 투자하는 사람도 있 있을
건데 MSTR를 투자하는 사람들
입장에서는 어 그냥 MSTR의 주가를
희석시키지 않고 계속해서 어 MSTR
그 주가가 계속해서 갈 수 있게 그런
그 프레임크를 제시해 주니까 굉장히
긍정적인 부분이었는데 비트코인을
투자하는 사람들 입장에서는 어
3.25빌리언 가치 정도의 비트코인만
팔면 이제이 이슈는 해소되는
것이다라고 볼 수가 있었거든요.
그래서 아 이번에는 당연히 비트코인을
팔아서 우리가 뭐 3.25 빌린
중에서 1빌년 뭐 2빌년 정도는
매도를 했겠다 이런 정도를 예측을
하고 있었는데 그게 아니라 반대로 어
MSTR 주주 가치를 훼손하는 어
MSTR ATM을 어 진행하다 보니까
충격이 좀 크고 비트코인을 투자하는
사람들 입장에서도 아 그 이슈가
해소되지 않았네라고 하면서 어 조금
더 가격이 흐름이 안 좋게 흘러가지
않았나 이렇게 저는 어 보고 말씀드릴
수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 어 두 번째 이슈도 한번 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 두 번째 이슈는
클레트가 예상치 못한 비보에 난
가능성을 겪고 있다라고 합니다.
그리고 트럼프는 어제 밤 다시 한번
크립토를 언급을 했는데요. 어 린지
괴염 그레엄이라고 하는 어 공화당 어
공화당 그 상원 의원이 있는데요.
지난주 갑자기 사망하는 사건이
있었습니다. 어 정확한 사인은 밝혀진
바고요. 뭐 사인이 중요한 건
아니지만 갑작스럽게 그냥
돌아가셨다라고 보시면 되는데 결국에
지금 클레티 액트가 상원에 머무르고
있습니다. 상원에서 어 투표를 진행을
해야 되는 상황인데 여기 그 글 어
여기 제가 기사를 좀 스크랩한 걸
보시면 렌지 그럼이랑 미치 메코넬이
두 분이 다 공화당 의원들이거든요.
상원에서 100명 100명 정도에서
60명 정도를 정 정도의 투표를
받아야지 어 그냥 필리버스트를 받지
않고 바로 통과할 수가 있는데 지벌서
공화당 위원이 두 명이 빠지다 보니까
친트럼프 그니까 친공화당 쪽의 어
법안인 클레리티 액트가 통과하지 못할
가능성이 좀 높아졌다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그래서 그렇게 코멘트가
나와 있는 기사를 스크
스크랩해왔다라고 보시면 될 거
같고요. 그리고 바로 밑에 있는
폴리마켓 확률은 좀 변동성이 심하긴
하지만 어 그래도 한 40% 이상으로
다시 한번 좀 급등을 해 오고
있었는데 다시 한번 30% 후반대로
떨어진 모습을 보실 수가 있을 것
같고 전이 두 가지 악자가 겹치지
않았나는 생각을 하고 있습니다.
그래서이 클레텍트가 통과되지 못한다고
하는 거는 어쨌든 어 크립토 시장에
어 유동성이 좀 들어오는 부분 어
규제적인 부분 때문에 들어오지 못했던
자금이 어 조금 더 늦어지거나
지연되거나 아니면 내년으로 밀리거나
그런 부분들이 있을 거라고 생각하기
때문에 그런 부분에서 조금 크립토
가격이 그리고 비트코 가격이 여러
가지 이슈와 복합적으로 안 좋지
않았나 이렇게 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같고 지난주에는 크 마이클 세일러가
비트코인을 팔면서 어 제가 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 그 이슈가 좀
해소돼가 해소돼 가는 과정 속에
지난주에 있었는데 이번 주는 어
그러면 그럼과 동시에 어 트럼프가
비트코인에 대해서 언급을 한번 해
줬고요. 그리고 거기다가 ETF까지
유입으로 들어서 돌아서다 보니까
지난주 한 주는 비트곤 가격이 조금
회복세 있었던 거 같습니다. 근데
이번 한 주 이번은 어제 어 전쟁이
격화되는 부분이 있어서 그런지
모르겠지만 트럼프가 트루 소셜에 어
렌지그레엄이 어 죽었지만 그를 좀
명예롭게 하기 위해서 클래틱스를
통과시켜야 된다. 그렇지 않으면
중국이 크리토와 AI 쪽에서 패권을
잡게 된다. 이런 식으로 갑자기 좀
강력하고 좀 비장하게 말을 해 줬지만
시장에서 전혀 반응이 없었습니다.
그래서 그 약효가 좀 떨어졌다.
그리고 트럼프가 이제 다시 크립토
시장을 펌핑해 주는 것에 어 좀 어
그런
레버리지가 좀 많이 떨어지지 않았나
하는 생각을 어제 하면서 어제 장을
조금 마무리 드릴 수가 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 좀 어 정리를 한번
드리면 어 마이클 세일러의 비트코인
매도에 대한 부분 그 이슈가 전혀
해소가 되지 않았고 어 클레리티 액트
가장 중요한 법안인 클레티 액트가 어
지금 다양한 이슈 때문에 그리고
결정적으로는 상원 의원들이 지금
자리를 비운 탓에 어 지금 통과
가능성이 좀 낮아졌다 어라고 말씀드릴
수 있을 것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 수주 전에도 준역하고
같은 얘기 했던 거 같은데
스트레티지는 스트리티지에 투자하는
주주들, 잠재적 주주들에게 비즈니스
모델을 좀 명확히 설명해 줄 필요가
있는데
>> 네.
>> 지금 저처럼이 코리니 상태에서 이해한
바로는
>> 투자하고 싶은 마음이 별로 안 들 것
같아요. 왜냐면
>> 이게 제가 직접 가상자산 예컨데 이제
비트코인에 투자하고 싶다고 했을 때
>> 네. 어, 직접 투자하는 방법과
스트레티지, 주식에 투자해서
간접적으로 코인에 투자하는 방법이
있을 텐데 후자인 경우의 상대적
장점은 어, 투자 방식에 따라서
배당을 받을 수도 있다. 그리고
>> 어, 코인 가격 올라가는 부분도
당연히 주가로 이제 향유가 될
거고요.
>> 그 자칫하면 어, 내가 내 돈으로
배당을 받는 것일 수도 있겠다.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 맞죠? 예. 그러니까
>> 어, 네. 어, 직접 투자하는 것보다
어떤 면에서든 조금이라도 좀 더
유리해야 스테지 주가 되려고 노력할
텐데 그 부분에 대해서 뭔가 좀 어
그러면은 어, 코인 가격이 지속적으로
우상향을 하면은 어, 이제 주주가
되는게 굉장히 좋은데
>> 뭐 그거 결국은 코인 가격이 위냐
아래냐를 예상하는 것이 비즈니스
모델이라면
>> 투자할 이유가 좀 적어지는 거 같아.
맞습니다. 그리고 그게 방금
말씀해주신 정확한 포인트가 어
정확하게 이제 MSI 지수 편출로도
이어지는데요. MSI 지금 보고
있는게 너네 사업 구조가 이렇게
비트코인을 바탕으로 자금 조달해서
비트코인을 운용하는 배당 그것도
배당으로 주고 우선주도 발행하고
이렇게 하는게 너네 사업 비즈니스
모델이면 너네는 투자 회사다라고
정의를 하는 거거든요. 그래서 만약
정말 그렇게 주주 가치를 훼손하고
소프트웨 사업은 아예 버리고 비즈니스
구조를 너네가 뭐네라고 설명했을 때
뭐라고 물어봤을 때 소프트웨어다라고
명확하게 설명할 수 없는 상황이 지금
계속 이어지고 있다 보니까 MC는
그걸 계속 째려보고 있고요. 그게
지수 편출로까지 이어진다라고 하면 어
스트레테지 주식 주주들한테는 더 안
좋은 소식이 하지 않을까? 그래서
지금 스트레티지를 투자하는 사람들은
뭐 장기 투자를 하는 투자들이 정말
많을지는 정말 잘 모르겠지만 어
투기적으로 하고 있는 분들이
계시다라고 하면 아까 말씀드린 그런
뭐 비트코인을 팔아서 스트레티지 주식
또는 스트레티지 우선주를 사겠다고
하는 그런 프레임워크에 단기적으로
들어간 분들도 조금 있을 거라고
생각합니다. 왜냐면 결국에 스트레티지
우선주가 100불의 패그가 원래 돼야
되는데 한 70% 거리가 되고 있으면
최소한 여기 정도까지 패그를 하려고
하는 노력이 지금 이어진다라고 하면
그 차익 거래를 좀 할 수 있거든요.
그래서 그런 부분들을 기대하고 한
투자자들이 많을 텐데 어 계속해서
비토 세일러가 반대 방향으로 가는
오히려 투자자들을 조금 어 속된 말로
엿먹이는 그런 행위 행동들로 가고
있다 보니까 여러 가지 측면에서
스트레티지의 주주가 되기에는 어려운
부분이 많은 거 같고
>> 지금 지수단에서도 스트레티지를 안
좋게 보고 있는게 거의 확실해지 가는
거 같습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 계속해서 업데이트
부탁드리겠습니다. 네. 오늘 채슬리
모닝 브리프 1부 여기서 마치도록
하겠습니다. 함께 해 주신 최밀텐
여러분 감사드리고요. 잠시 후
2부에서 뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
안녕하세요. 극복한 투자의 예정을
찰슬리 투자 전문과 함께 찰슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 14일 화요일 순서
시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자, 중동
사태가
쉽게 끝나지는 않는 모습이고 그죠?
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 지난번에 뭐 M 했을 때 어
이란에서도
이거 시간 끌기다.
워낙 국제 금리도 올라가고 육가도
불안하다 보니까이 세계 경제에 영향을
주는 거 같으니까
조금 미국이 더급하게 무유를 매든
다체
진정성은 없어 보이고 역시나
다시 또 재발되는 그런 모습인 거
같습니다.
예. 네. 그 국제 금리가 10년물
기준으로 어제 5.8bp
상에서 4.62를 찍었고요. 그리고
WTI도
8.9%가 상승하면서 77.89를
8구를 찍었습니다. 그러면서 어제
매크로 조합도 상당히 안 좋았고 아
또 어 창미프로가 얘기했듯이 아 국내
반도체 센티멘트가 안 좋으면서 아
그것이 미국 쪽에까지 좀 전되는
모습들이
관찰이 됐고요. 그러면서 필반 지수가
4.8%
하락을 했고요. 아우나 SMP 500
마스닥 하락을 했는데 SMP 500
주요 업종 지수를 보면은 아 그래도
구경제 주책들
방어 섹터에 있는 건강 관리나
금융이나 필수비제 에너지 부동산
유틸리티 어 이런 섹터들이 어 방어
해 주면서 SM은 -0.79% 79%
하락하면서 그나마 선방을 했고요.
현재 미증시 주요 지수 어 전고점
대비 하락률을 보면은 방금 말씀드린
범 S 범 미국 지수라고 할 수 있는
어 SNP 500이 -1.2%
나스닥이 -4.5% % 전고점 대비
하락한 상황이고 가우가 거의 신고가를
기록했다가 최근에 1.1% 정도
하락했고요. 러셀 2천이 2.4%
하락했습니다. 그리고 베타가 가장 큰
필반 지수가 15.6% 6% 정도
하락을 했는데 뭐 많이 오른 거에
대한음
그 차익 실전 또 솔리에 따른 딜
레버리징 섹터 수납 매크로 이슈 뭐
이런 부분들이 중첩되면서
어 또 올해 한 15% 정도 맥시멈
드로우다운이 몇 번 나왔었는데 아
이번에도 또 어 나온 상황이고요.
필반 지수 고점 대비 최대 하락률
보시면은 최근 5년간에 걸쳐서 좀
히스토리를 어 보면 좋겠다고 생각을
했는데 22년에 패드의 공격적 금리
인상이 있을 때 -46.6%까지
6%까지
고점 대비 최대 하락률이 나왔었고요.
그 밑에 비교적 그 방어 섹터가
많이 모여 있는 어 다우지수 같은
경우는 -21.9%
절반이 좀 안 되는 어 하락률을 어
보였었습니다.
그리고 25년 간세 충격이 있었을
때는
필반 지수가 고점 대비 최대
-39.7% 7% 거의 -40%까지
하락을 했었고요. 어 다우 지수가
-16.3% %을 했었습니다. 그리고
올해 같은 경우에 미일한 전쟁이 3월
달에 있었는데 그때 어 필반 지수가
-15%까지
고점 대비 최대 하락을 했었고요.
가오가 -10% 하락했습니다. 그
이후에 일반 지수가 계속해서 한
18일간 어 연속 오르면서 거의 뭐
100%까지 이렇게 올랐었고 다른
가우지수나 SP 500 나스닥 어
대비해서 상당히 아 폭품을 했었는데
어 그 이후에 한 15% 10% 이런
하락들이 좀 자주 나오고 있는
상황입니다. 그래서
어 이번에도 어 15% 고점 대비
최대 하락률이 나왔는데 이전에 10%
15% 이렇게 하락들이 좀 나오게
되면은 바로 좀 반등하는 모습들이
나오고 했었는데 이번에도 좀 그런
패턴이 이어지는지 한번 봐야 될 것
같고요. 이번에 그 특별히 그 조금
다른 양상을 보이는 거는 어 미 그
15%가 이렇게 하락을 했는데 어
다른 지수들 SM뱅이나 뭐 다우 지수
뭐 나스닥 러셀 2천 중용주나 뭐
방어 섹터가 모여 있는 지수라든지 범
미국 지수에 비해서 좀 낙폭이 크다는
거는 섹터 로테이션이 조금 격하게 어
일어나고 있지 않나 하는 느낌이
있고요. 그리고 우리나라에서도 뭐
자주 지적이 되고 있지만 반도체 쪽에
쏠린 아 딜 레버리징이 좀 격하게
이루어지고 있지 않나 싶습니다.
그래서 이런 부분들을 좀 포인트로
가져가야 될 것 같고 분명히 15%
이렇게 빠진 상황이기 때문에
종목별로는
마이크론이 뭐 고점 대비 22% 정도
하락 그랬고 어 다른 것들도 20에서
30% 정도 어 낙폭을 보이고 있는
상황입니다.
지정학적 리스크 어 초반에 전모님이
좀 말씀하셨는데이
말을들이 좀 왔다 갔다 하기 때문에
시장을 좀 혼란스럽게 하고 있는데
새로 나온 뉴스를 보면은 노란색 친
부분 보시면은 어 미국이 그
호르무즈 해협에 대해서 보호자 역할을
수행할 것이고 통과 화물에 대해서
20% 수준의 비용을 부과하겠다는
부상을 하고 있다라는 코 언급이
나오고 있고요.
그리고 현지 시간 16일 오전 9시
우리 시간으로는 17일 오전 오후
10시가 될 거 같은데
그때 어 대국민 어 연설을
예정하고 있다 이렇게 얘기를 하고
있습니다. 또 간혹간혹 나오는 그
뉴스들이 이란과 합의가 가능하다고
생각하고 있고 또 MO는 그냥
시험이었다. 뭐 이런 식으로 나
나오고 있어서 어 트럼프 대통령
특유의 지금 상
전술이 진행되고 있는 그런 상황인 거
같습니다. 그래서 이런 가운데 좀
시장이 혼란스럽기 때문에 아까
말씀드린 대로 WTI가 최근 1개월에
최고치 78% 아 78불를 기록했고
금리 10 미국체 10년물 기준으로
어 최근 1개월 내 최고치
4.6%까지 6%까지 올라 있는
상황입니다.이 두 매크로변수가
전반적인 시장을 압박하는 가운데
베타가 높은 종목이나 베타가 높은 어
지수에 특히 어 하락 압감을 하고
있는 그런 상황입니다.
이런 가운데 어제 어 TSMC 6월
매출이 나왔는데요. 6월 매출이 대만
달러로 442.7빌리언 7빌리언
달러가 나왔는데 아이 수치가 전년
동월 대비 67.9%가 9%가 증가한
수치입니다. 4월부터 5월, 6월
보시면은 월별로 봤을 때 전년 동월
대비 증가율이 좀 더 가속화되고 있는
모습인데 그래서 컨센 대비로는 얼마나
그 비트했나라고
봤는데 어 컨센은 소폭 상한
수준이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
6월 달 매출이 마무리되었기 때문에
2분기 매출을 합산할 수 합산해서 볼
수 있는데 2분기 전체 매출이 대만
달러로 1.27 출년 달러고요. 어
전년 동기 대비 36.1%가 1%가
증가를 했는데 컨센서스는
대만 달러로 1.26 출년 달러라서
컨센데 대비 매출 기준으로는 약간
상회한 수라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그래서 아주 서프라이징한
그런 수치는 아니었다 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같고요. 계속해서 어닝 시즌에
돌입하면서 기업들 실적 발표가 있을
텐데
그 분기별로
아 최근 한 20 최근 한 3년 정도
22년 3분기부터
최근까지 실제하고 아 컨센서스하고 어
실제하고
어 전년 동기 대비 이익 증가율이
어떤 식으로 직계가 됐나 이렇게
보면은
동그라미
그 22년 3분기 22년 4분기 그때
매크로 환경도 굉장히 험악했지만
실적도 컨셉 대비로
웬만해서는 어 실제치가 더 많이
나오는 편인데 어 22년 3분기에 어
실제 그 SP 500 기업들의 이익
증가율이 2.4%가 나왔고요.
컨센서스가 어 2.7% 정도
됐었습니다. 콘센 대비 안 나온 그런
분기였고 그게 22년 4분기까지
이어지면서 22년 4분기에는 오히려음
컨 그 전년 동기 대비 역성장하는
모습을 보였고 어 컨센 대비로도 더
안 나오는 그런 분기였습니다. 그
이후에 그 실적이 바닥을 찍고 어
컨센 대비로 잘 나오는 그런 분기들이
계속 이어지고 있고요. 참고로 이번
분기에 보면은
6월 달 현재로 집계한 22년 아
26년 아 2분기
이익 증가율을 보시면은 전년 동기
대비 23.2% 2% 정도 어
증가하는 증가할 걸로 어 예상이 되고
있습니다. 그래서 22년
어 하반기 쪽에 그 SNP 500
실적을 제외하면 지금까지 어 컨센
대비로 상당히 어 SP 500
기업들의 실적이 선방을 했었고 특히
이번에 나오는 어 수치 자체는 어
23% 정도 수준이라서 어 상당히 그
이전에 나왔던 실적보다는 좀 잘 나올
걸로 시장에서는 기대가 되고
있습니다. 전년 동기 대비
기준으로요. 그래서 2분기에 그
23.2% 지금 컨센이 형성이 돼
있는데 아 오늘 현재로 그 컨센서스가
상형 조정되면서 23.6%로
어 조금 올라갔고요. 어느 쪽이
기여를 하나 보면은 어 결국에는 IT
쪽이 63.3% 3% 전년 동기 대비
증가하는 걸로 예상이 되고 있어서
이쪽이 전체 SNP 500의 이익증
가율을 어 견인한다라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 에너지가 122%인데
전체에서 SP 500비에서 차지하는
비중 자체가 적기 때문에 기어도는 어
낮을 걸로 보고 있고
소재 쪽도 좀 어 존재감이 많지 않은
어 그 섹터고 그 큰 섹터 가운데
커뮤니케이션이 어 7.2%가 증가할
걸로 어 예상이 되고 있고 컨스머
디스크셔너리가
6.7%가 7%가 증가할 걸로 예상이
돼 있습니다. 비테크들이 속한
섹터인데 커뮤니케이션은
구글하고 메타가 있고요. 컨스머
디스크레션이 자유소비제에서는
아마존하고 어 테슬라가 있습니다. 한
자리수 정도
증가할 걸로 보고 있는데
조금 눈높이가 낮자 낮은 느낌이 있긴
있습니다. 지난번에도 좀 어 그러다가
그 실제로 실적을 열어 보니까
서프라이즈를 내곤 했었는데 이번에도
약간 그럴 가능성이 있지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있습니다. 아 오늘 밤에
아 6월 CPI가
발표가 되는데요. 헤드라인이 어제
말씀드렸던 대로 어 3.8%까지
어 내려왔습니다. 어 이전에 한
3.9% 9% 4%까지 이렇게 했다가
조금씩 내려오면서 컨센서스가 좀 낮게
잡힌 모양이 있는 거 같고요. 전월이
4.2%였습니다.
그리고 근원이 어 전 2.8%로
예상되고 있는데 전올은 2.9%로
예상되고 있습니다. 이것도 약간 조금
2.9% 정도라고 얼마 전까지
기억하고 있는데 컨센이 조금 어
낮아졌습니다. 그래서 시장에서 어
6월 CPI를 보는 시각 자체가 어
좀 낮게 나올 것이다라고 어 보고
있는데 이거는 조금 뚜껑을 열어봐야
될 것 같고요. 아 다행히 그
CPI에
헤드라인에 특히 영향을 많이 미치는
가솔림 가격 같은 경우에 어 5월에
많이 올랐다가 4.5불까지 5불까지
올랐다가 계속해서 떨어지면서
현재는 한 3.8불까지
내려온 상태입니다. 예년 25년에
비교해 보면은 어 그래도 아직 상당히
높은 편인데 어 유가에 따라서
연동되면서 움직일 것 같습니다. 이런
포인트들을 좀 어 봐야 될 거
같고요. 어, 결국 그
필반 지수가 좀 많이 빠져 있는데이
딜레버리징 섹터 순환매 이런 매크로
이슈들 어, 요런 부분들에 당분간 좀
영향을 받을 수 있 있는 어, 그런
상황인데 이전에 그 한 15% 정도
빠지면은 약간 어, 저가 매수세가 좀
들어왔기 때문에이 부분이 중에서 어느
한 부분만 약간의 그 완화 조집만
보여 보이더라도 도 반등할 수 있는
충분한 어 계기는 되지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있습니다. 이상입니다.
>> CPI가 이게 오늘 밤 9시 반에
나오네. 예, 그렇습니다.
최근 5년간 필반 지수이 MDD요
차트 어, 저도
어, 강의나 설명할 때요 자료 좀
이용해야 되겠네요. 보니까.
>> 네.
지난 1한 전쟁 때 정도 딱
빠졌네요. 보니까. 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 지금 얼마까지 우리 시장에 있어서도
뭐 삼성전자 하이닉스 지금 투자하신
분들이나 그 두 배리 레버리지
투자하신 분들이 많다 보니까 결국은이
반조체의 향방이 지금 제일 다들
궁금하실 거예요.
>> 예.
대체로 필반 지수하고 우리나라 지수
우리나라 이제 지수 중에서 삼성자
하이닉스가 50% 이상 처지하고 있기
때문에 비슷한 방향성, 비슷한
낙폭으로 가는데 오늘 그 보니깐 어제
종가 기준으로 코스피가 어 5점 대비
한 25% 정도 하락을 했더라고요.
그 어 그 일반적인 경향성으로 봤을
때는 어 코스피의 낙폭이 좀 과도하는
그런 느낌이 있습니다.
아무래도
네모리 반도체가 차지하는 비중이
50%가 남다 보니까
>> 네
>> 올라올 때도 과도하게 올라왔잖아요.
>> 네. 그렇습니다.
>> 네.
그래서 어떻게 보면
어 베타 개념 김유리 프로가 지난번에
이런저런 발표했을 때 제가 그 베타
개념을 얘기를 해 줬었죠. 업항
자체에 대한 부분보다는이 시장이
조정을 받을 때나 올라갈 때이 베타
개념도 우리가 중요시 봐야 된다고.
지금요 MD 차트 보면서 조금만 더
부현 설명을 좀 드리면
자 22년도에는
패드가 금리를 공격적으로 올리고
공격적으로 올린 이유는 물가를 잡기
위해서 그러면서 금리를 공격적으로
올고요. 근데 공격적으로 금리를
올린게 22년 10월이 시장이 저점을
쳤을 때가 그러면
금리를 올리다가 멈췄나? 아니잖아.
>> 네.
>> 예. 23년까지 금리 계속
올렸잖아요.
>> 그렇죠.
근데 금리를 올리는 속도가 어
22년도에 25로 시작해서 베이비
스텝으로 시작해서 그다음에 빅스텝
50 그다음에 자이언트 스텝 75를네
번이나 연속 때리고 그다음에 이제
50으로 다시 넘어가고 연준의
금리를 올리는 그 폭도 이것도
기울기값으로 보면
뭐 25 하는 거 아니었어. 그게
아니라 50, 75일 버린가 실량이
놀래 버리면서 저렇게 급락을 하는데
22년도에 그러면 반도체가 안
좋았나? 22년도에 반도체 좋았어요.
되게 22년도에 반도체가 안 좋아서
저렇게 빠진게 아니에. 그게 베타
개념을
어 그때도 유리프로가 모르는 거
같아서 베타 개념이라는게 있다는
거죠. 시장에 대한 민감도라이
시장에 대한 민감도에서 다우 밑에도
다우가 나오지만 다우 차트 같이 해
놓으셨잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 요때 다우가 20% 조금 넘게
빠졌죠.
>> 예.
그래서이 베타 개념이
어 일반인들은 잘 모르고 매니저들도이
베타 개념에 대해서 조금이 강구하는
경우가 많은데 시장이 약세장으로
흘러갔을 때 포트폴리오를 어떻게
가져가야 되나라는 부분에 있어서 어
베타를 낮추는 플레이를 거기에 펀더
매니저 설베이에서 이성준 대표서장이
한 번씩 해 줄 때 매니저들의 포지션
변화 보여주잖아요.
>> 그 걔네들은 굉장히 정석대로 하고
있는 거예요.
>> 어, 시장이 약세장으로 흘러간다면
베타를 낮추기 위해서 베타를 낮추는
방법은 SP 500을 베타 1이라고
봤을 때 SP 500보다도 더 베타가
높은게 나스닥. 나스닥보다도 베타가
높은게 필반. 그리고 필반보다도
베타가 최근에 높았던게 이제 딜램.
좀 메모리 반도체 약간 그런 성격이
있었고
어 그래서이 뭐 근데 디램은 최근에
이제 AI 인플란스 사이클에 크게
최근에 호황이 오면서 어 항상 그런
건 아니었기 때문에
>> 예 필반하고 나스닥하고 SP
오브약하고 다우 요렇게 이제 설명을
많이 들었었죠.
그래서 22년도에도
어 이런 것들이 보면 업항에 의한
조정이라기보다는
외상적 변수에 의한 조정이라는 거죠.
속 외상적 변수에 의한 조정인데
이때는 패드가 공격적으로 금리를
높일 때였고 23년에 보면
MDD도 저렇게 줄어들고 23년도에
어 필반 지수 그다음에 우리나라
삼성전자 하이닉스 다 올랐어요. 다
올랐는데 23년도에
어 삼성전자가 6조 6천억 이익 영업
이익이 나고 하이닉스가 7조천억
손실이 났을 때죠. 그렇게 어닝
쇼커들이 나오는데
필반 지수도 올라가고 삼성전자
하이닉스도 다 올라갔어요.
>> 23년도에 88%인가 하이닉스가
올라가고
>> 삼성전자도 40% 이상 올라갔어.
그래서 지금도이
어 계속 어닝 대비해서 PR 얼마
이런 식으로 이제 우리가 잣대를 갖다
대면서 아 도대체 비싼 것도 아니고
그죠. PR이 멀티플레 비싼 것도
아니고 이익은 다음 분기 다섯 분기
어떤 분들은 28년 초까지
좋아진다는데
아니 왜 이렇게 주식은 왜 이렇게
빠지는 거야? 그걸 갖다가 이번 7월
전망이나 얘기할 때도 계속 사람들이
자기 체력만 믿고 아유 날씨 아유 뭔
날씨 산에 갔는데 뭔 날씨를 봐 난
체력 좋은데 그런 건 제가 똑같다는
얘기를 하는 거죠. 내 체력만 좋으면
되지 뭔 날씨를 체크해.
근데 우리가
주식 투자라 하는 거는 어 에베르스트
산에 올라가는 등정처럼
굉장히
그 위험하기도 하고 어 신중하게 해야
돼요.
뒤동산이나
뭐 뒤통산은 아니지만 어 북한산 정도
뭐 청개산 정도 올라간다고 해도 어
지난번에 우면산 산태처럼
이게 포구가 쏟아지고 이럴 때는
조심해야 되는 거죠. 그래서 지금
최근에이 반도체 투자하시면서
놀리신 분들이 되게 많을 거예요. 뭐
정부도 지금 놀라고 있을까요?
그런 부분에 있어서 정확하게 우리가
알아야 될 개념은
배터는 배터 시장이 그러면 뭐가 뭐가
시장을 떨게 만드느냐 뭐가 시장을
떨게 만드느냐는 개념에서 제가 목욕탕
온도 얘기했었잖아. 그래서
10년물 국채 금리가 4.4 아
4.4만 해도 좀 뜨거운데 4.5
45°
46° 46도는 못 앉아 있는 그래서
45° 46° 여기에 해당되는 심령물
국제가 4.5 4.6 이렇게 갈 때는
어
뛰쳐나오게 돼 있던 사람들이 아가
하면서 뛰쳐나오게 돼 있는데
그중에서도 이제 베타가 큰 섹터들이
지수가 더 먼저 놀래 가지고
뛰쳐나오는 그런 모습들이
나오는 거고 그래서 지금 어이란
전쟁이 확실하게 이제 종전된 것도
아니고 그다음에요 MDD 다시 한번
보면음
22년도에도
9월 10월 10월 11일 정도 예
미국 시장이 바닥을 쳤었죠.
>> 예. 우리 시장은 이제 9월 말에
바닥을 쳤었고 그리고 23년도에도
쭉 보면 23년도에 장 좋았다
이랬잖아요. 반도체 좋았다
그랬잖아요. 근데 좋았는데 종가
기준으로 보면 23년 디버 요때 보면
MDD가 거의 빵이 돼. 근데 중간에
23년 8, 9, 10월 달에 10월
달에 보면이 MDD가 -2이 넘어가.
>> 그러면 이때 -2이 넘어갔던 거는
금리 때문이라고. 그때도
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 금리가 10년물이 4.99까지
이제 올라가면서
그러면 아무리 뭐가 좋다 해도 어 그
신앙이 금리가 주는 공포는 모든
자산에 영향을 미친다는 거죠. 그것도
베타가 높은 자산에 영향을 많이
준다는 거죠. 자, 그러고 나서 이제
회복하면서 연말 되니까 다
올라오잖아요. 이번에도 굉장히이
비슷한 패턴이 저는 된다고
비슷한 그다음에 24년도에도 쭉
넘어가 보면 24년도에도 24 돼
있고 주은 돼 있죠. 주운 그다음에
줄라이 그리고 어스트 세템 요렇게 쭉
갈 건데 아니 이때도 보니까
24년도에도 MDD가 거의 25까지음
그죠?
네. 24년 8월 달에 엔리
트레이드이 있었고 그 쌍바닥 치는
모습으로 다시 어 한번 더 빠졌다가
올라가는데 요때가 이제 모건 수도님이
>> 반도체 겨울 얘기 나오면서 쌍바닥
만들고 그러면서 스물스물 올라가는
모습이 나오고
자 그다음에는 뭐 25년대만
어 트럼프의 반세 폭탄이었으니까
그래서요 7 8월 달이 보면 7,
8, 9월 달이 보면 어 어떻게 보면
조심을 해야 되는데 최근에 금리가
어땠었나? 계속 고공 행진하고
있었다. 고공 행진 그러면 고공
행진을 하는 이유는 뭔가? CPI가
2.3까지 갔다가 최근에 4.2까지
올라가는
>> 그런 모습도 나오면서 여러 가지
면에서
금리를 자극하고 10년부 국제 금리는
육가급 저렇게 빠지는데 왜 안
빠지나?
어 뭐가 문제인가? 기대 인플레이션은
앞으로 떨어지게 돼 있는데 실제
금리가 그러면 안 떨어지나?
실제 금리에서 최근에 빅테크들이 계속
돈 당겨 가고 어떻게 보면 미국 정부
입장에서도
상호관세가
위원으로 나오면서 어 거기에 환급을
해 주고 있죠.
음.
>> 아, 거기에 추가적으로 그 국채를
찍어서 그 한번 돈 돌려 주는이는
여러 가지 면에서 아, 실적 금리가
조금 빡빡할 수도 있겠다.
이런 부분에 있어서 침용 국제 금리가
4% 4.4 넘는 상황에서 계절적으로
계절적으로 네. 계절적으로 보면요
789는 우리가 조심해야 되고 어
아예 안 하는 것도 방법이 나죠. 안
하는 것도 일반인들 분들 중에서
그래서 계좌 듣고 오히려 7월 달에
여행 다녀 오시는게 나을 거라고 그런
말씀을 드리면서 쉬는 것도 투자다
이런 여러 가지 말씀을 들었는데 어
지금 이제 온몸으로 이제 당하고
계시는 분들 입장에서 어떻게 해야
되냐 이게 중요하잖아요. 그죠? 쓰게
중요한데
체약의 경우 해 봐야
23년 8, 90대처럼
그런 생각 해 봐요. 어 그러면 일반
지수 기준으로는 -2 살짝 터치하는
예. 정도라 부분.
어, 지금
뭐 반도체 업항에 대한 전방 산업에
대해서는 워낙 저보다 많은 분들이 그
전문가분들이 어, 지금 전방이
좋다라는 걸 얘기해 주고 계시기
때문에 그리고 필반 지수에는 메모리만
있는게 아니라 메모리만 있는게 아니라
어, 반도체 장비도 있고 M비D도
있고 AMD도 있고 여러 가지가 있기
때문에 그래서 이번에 필반의 어
저점은 많이 안 좋아 봐야 저기
23년 890 왜냐면 23년 890에
금리가 5%까지 갔었을 때 어 어느
정도까지 빠졌느냐를
보여 준 거기 때문에
그래서 어 좀 789 중에서 7월
달에 이번에 좀 세게 맞았고 거기에
이런저런 리포트 나오고 거기에 또
호르무저 해업에
재봉쇄 뭐 이런 것들이 노이자들이 어
생긴 거고요. 그때 23년 10월
달에는
어 이스라엘 하마스 전쟁이 터지고 예
그때도 뭐 평온했던 건 아니에요.
>> 오히려 이스라엘 하마스 전쟁 터지고
나서 10월 달에 그때부터 금리 다시
오히려 떨어졌어요.
우리나라 시장은 좀 베타가 우리나라
시장 자체도 베타가 높은 시장이다
보니까 그때 우리나라 시장은 23년
어 10월 말까지 좀 안 좋았긴
내었었지만
그래서 이미 그 보면 항상 가치 대비
이제 주가 가격이 어떻게
움직이는가인데
가격이 싸지면 싸질수록 오히려 더
안전한 거고자
가격이 고공 행진하면서 막 어 거품이
이 생기고 오버시팅 나오고 이럴 때가
위험한 거지. 이미 고점 대비 뭐
25% 우리나라 시장 아니 27% 뭐
이렇게 빠지면 오히려 지금부터는
안전한 영력으로더.
>> 음.
그래서 전체적으로는 6,300에서
9,300 아니면 6,800에서 한
9,800 요렇게 이제 하반기를 제가
박스로 예, 생각을 했었는데
9,900 정도 그렇다면 지금 어
6,800원이
여기서부터는
여기서부터는 겁날 이유가 없어요.
이 그런데 이제 레버리지를 쓰고
있으신 분들은 뭐 극도로 지금
공포스러워지겠죠. 예. 신용도 지금
좀 틀리고 있는 거 같고. 예.
어 혈반 지수의 MDD 그동안에이
동량을 보면요 MDD가 참 좋은게 아
그래서 어떤 외상적 변수에 스트레스를
줬을 때 스트레스 테스트 과거에
스트레스 테스트라고 보시면 아이 정도
스트레스에서 주가는이 정도로 반응을
반응을 했었구나
그렇게 보시면 될 거죠.
자, 국내 시장 보면서 또이 얘기를
좀 더 이어가 보도록 하고요.
시장으로 넘어가 보도록.
네. 전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 9% 가까이 하락하면서
6,800포인트로 마감을 했었고요.
코스닥은 약 799포인트로
800포인트를 깨고 내려앉았습니다.
수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인 투자자가
3조 8천억 가량 현물 매수세가
유비됐었고요. 외국인과 기관에선
조단이의 매도가 나왔습니다. 외인
선물 쪽에선 1조 3천억 가량
매수세가 유입이 되기도 했었고요.
투자별 매매 동향으로 보면 외국인
투자자는 LG노텍, SK 스퀘어,
현대차, 한미반도체, 삼성 물산 등을
매수를 했었고 반면 매도에는 SK닉스
1조 4,억대 그리고 삼성전자,
삼성전기, KB 금융, 삼성 SDI,
원익 IPS 등을 매도했습니다. 어,
기간 매수에는 PSK, 대덕전자,
KB금융, SOL, 원익, IPS,
테스 등을 매수를 했고요. 매도에는
기관쪽도 하이닉스에 대한 매도가 좀
많았는데요. 1조 4,억 대도 있었고
그 외에 삼성전자, SK 스퀘어,
삼성전기, LG 이노택 등을
매도했습니다.
52주 신고가 종목은 총 다섯
종목이었는데 코스피에서 KB 금융,
하나 금융 지주, SO1, 우선주,
그리고 한성 기업 이렇게네 종목이
있었고요. 코스닥에서는 스펙 관련주
한 종목이 있었습니다.
음.
자, 야간 선물은 -0.1 일파 예,
별로 안 빠졌습니다. 예. W EWY
한국 ETF는 실을 후반영하면서
-8.36
빠졌고 하이닉스 ADR도 9%
빠졌다고 그죠?
자, 주요 종목들 동향 한번 쭉
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 살펴보면 대형
반도체가 심하게 빠지면서 아래
소부장까지 같이 무너지는 흐름이
나왔는데요. 어 삼성전자가 10%
급락이 나왔었고 SK닉스가 15%
급락했습니다. 아래 소부장 조목들도
대체한 5% 이상의 낙폭을 보였는데
HPSP, 이오테크, 파크 시스템즈,
주성 엔지니어링 등이 약세였고요.
그리고 아래 심택이 한 12% 정도
급락세를 보였고 두산테스나도 한 7%
이상의 낙폭을 보였습니다. 그래도 좀
견조했던 종목들이 있긴 했었는데
ISC가 1.5%
상승세를 보이기도 했었고요. 원익
IPS는 보합 정도 수준으로 마감을
하면서 시장 대비로 좀 많이 강한
편이었습니다. IT 섹터에서 삼성
전기가 18% 급락이 나왔습니다. 어
무라타가
제가 일본장 열리고 나서 딱 봤을 때
한 2, 3%밖에 안 빠지고
있었거든요. 근데 전기가 한 7%
8% 하락하고 하락폭을 좀 확대하다
보니까 어 니케이 지수에 있는 무라타
뭐 이비든 이런 종목들도 뭐 10%씩
빠지더라고 결국에는. 그래서 좀
동조화되는 흐름이 나타났었던 거 같고
LG 이노텍도 11% 가량 급락세를
보였고요. 뭐 나머지 종목들도 대체로
비슷한 흐름이었습니다. 플랫폼 섹터는
시장 대비로는 나쁘지 않았는데요.
네이버 카카오가 1%대의 하락률
기록했고 카카오 페이는 오히려 또
상승세를 보이기도 했습니다. 어제
니케이 지수 2%가라 하락
마감했습니다. 어 도쿄 일렉트로니아
2% 하락했고요. 불라타가 8%
이비니 약 8% 가량 하락세를
보였습니다. 어드반 테스트도 좀
약했고요. 어제 중국 쪽인가 대만 쪽
MSC 회사가 한가를 가기로
했었거든요.
>> 근데 뭐 특별한 이슈나 이런 거는
없었는데
>> 좀 그런 많이 올랐던 반도체 내에서
많이 올랐던 섹터에 대한 어 매도세가
좀 강하게 집중됐던 영향이 아닌가
그런 생각이 좀 들었고요.
배터리 체인 어 좋았습니다. 엔소리
보합 정도의 상승률 SDI가
1.4%가량 오르면서 어 시장 대비로
굉장히 강한 모습이 전일 좀
나타났었고요. 자동차 섹터 현대차
기아 대체로 부진했습니다. 소비제
섹터 나쁘지 않았는데요. 생건이
1.4, 코스맥스가 6.7
코스메카 코리아가 6.8%가 8%가
상승세를 보이면서 어 최근에 소비주
쪽에 화장품이 좀 괜찮은 상황인 거
같고요. 미용 기기도 좋았는데요.
클래시스를 제외하고 파마리서치 휴젤,
APR이 또 상승세를 보이기도
했습니다. 농식률 섹터는 어 농심이
보합이었고요. 시품량 2.5%량
하락으로 마감했습니다.
어 백화점 섹터는 어 최근 들어서 좀
많이 약한데요. 신세계가 6% 빠졌고
현대 백화점이 한 5% 가량
납부였습니다.
어 조선 철감이 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주 어제 뭐 부진한 흐름 나왔었고
SK 이노베이션이 7% 또 오르기도
했습니다. 그리고 유가가 좀 튀다
보니 SO1이 최근에 좀 주가가 도는
모습이 어 계속해서 이어지는 거
같고요. 방산주들은 뭐 전쟁이 좀
이어진다라는 이야기가 나와도 최근에
주가는 뭐 전쟁과는 크게 연관없이
반응을 하고 있는 상황입니다.
하에어로가 3.2, 넥스1 3.2,
현대의 로템 5% 가량 하락세
보였습니다. 그 아래 바이오 섹터는
삼성 바이오가 0.3%가나 3%가나
상승했고요. 에피스 홀딩스는 어제 장
끝나고 좀 호재가 나왔던 걸로 알고
있는데요. 장 끝나고 좀 주가가
NXT자 시간으로 좀 오르더라고요.
SC 기술에 대한 성공 뭐 이런 거에
대해 이런 기사가 나왔는데 결국에이
정맥 주사가 아니라 애나 이런데 피아
쪽으로 주사하는 방식인데 그 부분에서
좀 호재성 이슈가 나오면서 어제
시간으로 좀 반응이 괜찮았었던 거
같고요. 요 아래 바이오섹터는 대체로
다 코스닥 바이오, 코스피 바이오
부진했습니다.
확실히 은행주가 좀 탄탄한
흐름인데요. KB 금융이 1% 정도
상승세를 보였고 아래 증권 부진했고
엔터 쪽도 부진한 하루였습니다.
그리고 반도체가 무너지다 보니 변화기
섹터도 동반에서 좀 최근 원스
기준으로 낙폭이 좀 크게 나타나고
있는데 현대 1이 30% 빠졌고요.
효성 중금 20% LS 1일렉도
17%
빠지면서 변합기 섹터도 굉장히 부진한
상황입니다. 그래서 밸류에이션도
변합기 쪽도 이전 대비 많이 저렴해진
상태까지 어 빠진 상황입니다.
예. 저 기업들 동량 받고요. 자,
어제 또 약간 논란이 됐던게이
한투 최민수 경구원의 리포트. 우리가
아침 어제 모닝 브리퍼에서 얘기할
때도 어 이번에 하이닉스가 이제
컨센을 좀 할 가능성이 높다. 요런
얘기가 나왔었는데이 리포트가 언제
나온 거예요?
어제데 대체로이 리포트가
일요일 늦은 밤에 나오면 그 발간
일자가 월요일로 표기되는 경우가
있거든요. 근데 제가 일요일에는
확인해 보지 못해서 잘 모르겠는데
근데 어제 장 열리기 전에 나온 건
맞습니다.
>> 자 제목이 SK 하이닉스의 EQ 리뷰
아 프리뷰네
잠깐만이 EQ 7월 29일 날
나오죠. 이번에 전자가 30날이고
프리뷰 LTA를 반영한 추정치
현실화라고 돼 있느다 한번
보겠습니다.
네. 한토 최명숙 연구원님
자료였고요. 2분기 실적은 컨센서스를
좀 화야할 것으로 추정을 했습니다.
2분기 매출액은 80조대 보고
있고요. 영업익은 60.4조원 조원
전망했는데 영업 이행인 컨센서스
65조원을 약 8% 정도 하여할
것으로 보고 있고요. 경쟁사 대비
HBM 매출 비준이 높아서 시장 평균
대비 ASB 상승률이 낮았기
때문이라고 합니다. 다만 HBN4가
본격적으로 양산 판매되는 3분기부터는
시장 평균 수준의 ASP 상승률을
기록할 것으로 보고 있고요. 2분기
디램과 랜드 ASP는 전분기 대비
각각 약 30%
50% 정도 상승한 것으로 추정을
했습니다. 추정치 현실라는 LTA를
반영한 결과라고 하는데요. 26년과
27년 영업 이익 추정치는 기존 대비
각각 9% 어 11% 하향 조정을
했고요.이는 실적 악화 우려이 아니라
최근 내 LTA를 반영해 가격 과정을
현실화한 결과라고 하고요. 메모리
산업이 3년에서 5년 정도 LTA
중심으로 변화되면서 기업 가치는
분기별 ASP 상승률보다는 높은
수익성이 얼마나 오랫동안 유지되는지가
더욱 중요해질 것으로 보고 있습니다.
전사 영업률은 26년 2분기
74.6%로 6%로 역대 최고치를
기록한 이후에도 매분기 꾸준히 상승할
것으로 예상을 했고요. HM4는
3분기부터 본격 양산에 들어가고
27년부터는 장기 공급 계약 가격이
적용이 되면서 어 Hmm 상승이 디램
블렌디드 ASP 상승을 견인할 것으로
추정을 했습니다. 타겟 프라이스는
380만 원 유지를 했고요. 비중학대
의견도 유지를 했습니다. 앞으로는
이익 규모보다 수익성 지속 가능성이
핵심 투자 포인트로 보여진다라고
하고요. LTA 확대는 메모리 산업의
구조적인 실적 변동성을 낮추고 있고
계약 기반 매출 비중 확대나 HM
생산 확대로 인한 일반 매물리
공제약이 이어지면서 높은 수익성이 좀
더 장기간 유시될 것으로 본다.
그래서 향후 밸루에이션은이 규모
자체보다는 이익의 지속 가능성을
반영하는 방향으로 리팅될 가능성이
높다라는 이야기를 했습니다. 그래서
추정치는 뭐 떨궜고요. 그리고
컨센서스를 하여 할 것이다라고 했는데
일단 전반적인 톤 자체는 긍정적인
뷰는 유지를 한 모습이고요. 타겟
프라이스도 유지를 했고 비중확대
의견도 유지를 했는데 어쨌든 LTA가
제가 알기로 그 이세 연구님이 나와
그 방송에 나오셔서 오히려 LTA는이
메모리 반도체 주가에 부정적인 영향을
미칠 수도 있다. 이런 얘기 했던
걸로 기억이 나는데
>> 음이
>> LTA가 확정이 되면은이 가격이
올라갈 수 있는 룸을 막아 버린다는
뜻으로도 해석을 할 수 있잖아요.
제가 알기론 하이닉스는 상하단이 없는
걸로 하단은 있는데 이제 상단은 없는
걸로 알고 있거든요. 그래서 가격이
계속 올라갈 수 있는 걸로 알고
있는데 이제 전자나 마이크로는 상단은
좀 정해져 있는 걸로 알고 있고 근데
최근에 나오는 오늘도 미래세증권
리포터도 나왔는데 또 LK 때문에 그
이익 추정체를 좀 떨궈낸 모습이 또
나타다라고 나타나더라고요. 그래서
애널리스트 분들은 뭔가를 들었기
때문에 그렇게 했을 거 같긴
한데요.이
부분은 좀 확인해 볼 필요가 실적
발표때 아마 이야기를 좀 해 주겠죠.
인스측에서 그래서 그럴 때 좀 확인을
해 볼 수 있지 않을까라는 생각이
듭니다. 아래 실적 추장치로 내려가서
보면
컨센서스보다 확실히 낮게 올해 영업
이익을 또 전체적으로 추정을 하고
있는데요. 매출액 기준으로 326조를
전망하고 있고 어 영업 이익은
245조
정도 전망을 하고 있는데요.
오른쪽 표로 가서 보면 제가 최근에
7월 달 이후에 나왔던 SK
하이닉스에 대한 리포트들을
쭉 정리를 해 봤는데 증권사별로
나옵니다. 근데 최민숙 연구원님이
올해 예상 영업 이익을 240조
불렀잖아요. 최근에 BNK 이민이
연구원님이나 대신 유영근 아 대신
류현근 연구님도 아마 최근에 그
의견은 조금 톤다운한 걸로 알고
있는데 영업 이익이 보수적으로 보시는
분들도 한 270조 이상은 보고
있거든요. ENK 이민 연구님은
내년에 감익으로 찍어 놓긴 했지만
근데 이번에 최민순 연구원님은 올해
영업 이익 자체를 굉장히 좀 낮게
보고 있는데이 부분이 올해
하반기부터는 LTA 물량들이 좀 찍힐
거고 그리고 HBM이
상대적으로 지금 디램보다는 이익이
이익 마진이 적기 때문에 그런 부분을
좀 많이 반영을 해서 이익을 많이
떨은 거 같다라는 생각이 들었습니다.
그래서 최근 이런 분위기가 조금 계속
나오고 있는 거 같아요. 오늘 미래스
측권에 리포트 나온 걸 보면
뭔가 다른 이야기가 애널리스 분들한테
좀 들린게 아닌가 생각이 좀 들고 그
아래는 이제 삼성전자와 SK닉스
주가 추위를 좀 넣어 놨는데요. 지금
전차 기준으로는 고점 대비 전일 종가
기준 32% 빠져 있는 상황이고 SK
하이닉스는 38%가 빠졌더라고요.
하이닉스가 많이 빠져 있는데 차트한
봤을 때 삼성전자는 이격도를 많이
좁혀 놓은 상황이고 하이닉스는 사실
삼성전자가 저기 초록색선이
볼린저 밴드 중단인데 사실 20주
2평선이라고 봐 주시면 되거든요.
저기 미세하지만 20주 2평선과 지금
겹쳐 있습니다. 20주 2평까지
전자는 내려온 상황이고 하이닉스는
아직 20주 2평선까지 내려가려면 좀
더 많이 더 빠질 룸이 남아 있다라고
볼 수가 있기 때문에 일단 하이닉스가
좀 하락이 멈춰 줘야 뭐 다른
종목들도 좀 반등할 것 같은데
아직까지 이경만 봤을 때는 좀 더
좁혀질 여력도 남아 있다라는 생각이
듭니다.
문은 좀 전에 그 LTA를 반영한
결과요 논란에 대해서는 어떻게 생각?
음.
LT가 이제 가격을 3년에서 5년
이제 어느 정도
>> 레인지를 좀 확정해서 가져가 나가서
수요측에서는 물량을 안정적으로
공급받을 수 있고 가격적으로도 부담을
이제 덜 수 있는 그런 맥락이고
공급측에서도 장기 공급 계약을
맺으니까 수요의 예측 가능성을 높일
수 있어서 멀티플 관점에서 좀 도움이
되는 어 그런 이야기라고
생각하는데요. 어 제가 뭐 한 3주
정도부터 말씀을 드려봤지만은
>> 피에서는 이제 조금 한기 굳이는 음
>> 여러 대회적 노이즈들이 굉장히
많아지고 있는 거 같아요.
>> 그래서 앞으로는 이제 Q 관점으로
성장을 명해 나가야 되는데
삐끗하면은
공급 노이즈가 날 수도 있어요.
그래서 Q는 되게 섬세하게 다뤄야
되는 그런 메모리 산업에서는
영역입니다.
다만 그
AI 전용 반반 반도체 같은 LCBM
요런 비중이 사실
계속 높았으면은
레거시 메모리 비중이 적어지기 때문에
이런 시크리클 변동성이 줄어들었겠지만
HBM을
찍다 보니깐 레거시가 급등을 해
버렸죠. 그래서 결국 HB중 HBM
비중이 늘지 못했어요.
한 2년 전 전 전 전망치대로라면
지금 HBM 비중 50% 됐어야
됐어요. 근데 반사 작용으로 레거시가
이제 소티즈로 급등해 버리니까 지금도
HBM 비중 시에서도 20%밖에 안
>> 그래.
>> 그래서
>> 어
>> 결국에는
>> 물론 이제 주가가 빠르게 반영해 줘서
되게 모드가 해피했죠. 그렇지만은 어
좀 멀티플 관점에서 좀 아쉬움이 좀
남는 상황이고 그럼 지금은 80%는
시크리콜 관점으로 봐야 될 것 같아.
20%는 이제 성장 관점으로 보고
그러면 이제 물량이 중요하잖아요.
근데 지금 중국에서 계속 치고
올라오고 있는 모습들이 굉장히 많이
신경 쓰고 있다라고 말씀드렸고
애플에서도 탑재 여부에 대해서
타진하고 있다. 이런 것들이 같은
맥락이라고 보여주고 있어요. 제가
지금 추 중심으로 성장해야 되는데
사실
코로나 때도 마찬가지였어요.
코로나 때 우리 미디어 굉장히 많이
보고 집에서 많이 보다 보니까 텔픽이
폭중했죠. 음. 근데 이게 계속될
걸로 우리는 단계적으로 그냥 보고
있었던 거죠. 그래서 이거 이거는
수요자 측면 아니 측면이뿐만 아니고
공급자 측면도 같은 사람이기 때문에
이게 계속될 거라고 생각을 해서
케텍스 투자를 엄청 때려박았습니다.
그래서 공급이 또 훅 나오면서 또
사이클이 꺾였죠. 근데 지금도 시크럽
비중이 이렇게 높은 상황에서는
같은 관점을 투용해 볼 수 있는 그런
맥락이기 때문에 공급 관점에서 되게
조심을 해야 돼요. 근데 이렇게
대회적으로 이렇게 막 선언할 정도의
그런 분위기가 형성되면 사실 주가에
도움이 안 돼.
그런 막 반점은 경 기업에서도 좀
조심해야 되고 중국 관련해서도 조금
계속 저희가 완측을 해야 되는 그런
맥락인데 6MT가 이제는 랜드 쪽
랜드 쪽도 좀 들어가 관심을 보이고
있는 거 같고요. YMTC는 디램
쪽으로 관심을 보이고 있는 거
같아요.
>> 디램 케파를 실제로 올리겠다고 하고
있어요. 그럼 대을 실시냄
어 올해 350k니까
어 마이크로 380k 정도 되거든요.
마이크로는 수준까지 올해 오고
내년에는 마이크로는 넘어설 거
같아요. 음
>> 그러면서
>> 디램이
>> 예 레거시 디램 5 16난노
>> 어
>> 그러면 어 중국 유럽에 나가는 지금
주력 라인업이
디젤 5 16 라인업으로 지금 침투할
수 있는 맥락이거든요. 그래서 일부
들어가고 있어요. 유럽에는. 그래서
그런 관점에서 물량이 늘게 되면은 그
B2C 마켓에서도 트림트가 조금씩 될
거 같아요. 지금 시기에 왜냐면 지금
너무
물량이 없다 보니까 중국라도 좀
쓰자하고 애플이 얘기하는 거잖아요.
요런 하나하나가 다 시그널이 돼서
지금 시장에 논란이 되고 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서 휴 관점에서 지금
좀 조심해야 되는 그런 시기예요.
그렇지 않으면 또 다시 코로나
시기처럼 그런 우려가 나올 수 있기
때문에 지금이라도 더 다시 정책을
다시 다 재정하는게 더 좋을 것
같습니다.
자, 그리고 어,요
리포트 내용하고 이제 최근에
얘기되는요
LTA가 사실은 그동안에 LTA
때문에 아, 이렇게 메모리 반도체
지금 최근에 좋다가
또 산이 높았기 때문에 또 1, 2년
지나고 나면 또 물량 확 Q 수요단의
Q죠.
단에서 큐가 확 줄어들면서 또 가격
폭락하고 뭐 이러는게 메모리 사
메모리 산업 아니냐 이런 부분에
아니다. 요즘은 장기 공급 계약으로
지금 3년 5년치 앞으로 이제 거의
확정시키고 있다. 이걸 좋게 봤던
거잖아.
>> 음. 그러면 이제 사이클이
오펜다운이이
진폭이 줄어들면서 메모리 쪽도 어
PBI이 아니라 이제 PER로 평가를
해 주고 리레이팅을 해 줘야 된다.
요런 얘기였는데 오히려이 LTA를
적용을 하면서 어 장기 공급 계약을
이미 3년에서 5년치를 해 버리면 더
이상 스팟 가격이 계속 올라가더라도
이제는 굳자가 된다는 거지. 구자
논란은 그 얘긴 거 같아요. 구원자가
돼서 우리가 주식 투자할 때 어
이익의 기울기 그런 얘기 많이
하잖아요. 그러면 영업 이익률이 이제
피커 아웃 친 거 아니야? 그
그러면서 이제 모건 스탠니 얘기도
이익률이 피커웃 친 거 아니야? 뭐
요런 얘기를 하더.
근데 그 말도 맞긴 맞아요. 만약에
LTA가 100%라고 정했을 때
3년에서 5년을 갖다가
확정을 시켜 버리면 더 이상 이제
OP 마진이 물론 이제 OP 마진에서
P를 확정시키고 Q를 확정시켰으니까
거기서 이제 C를 줄이면 그만큼 또
줄어들겠죠. 늘어나겠죠. 영업이.
근데 코스트에서는 최근에 뭐
노사하기한 부분이 있어서 C는 오히려
늘어났어요. 솔직히 C가 늘어났어.
PQC에서. 그리고 P랑 Q를 만약에
고정을 시켜 버렸다고 하면 어떻게
보면 어
5점이네. 뭐 요런 얘기가 지금
성립이 된다는 거죠. 이제 더 이상
못 올라간다.
>> LTA 때문에. 그동 그전에는 이제
LTA 때문에 메모리 사이클이 업앤
다운이 왔다 갔다 하는게 이제
둔화된다 했는데 이제는 그걸 가지고
또 약간
>> 그걸 단점으로 얘기하는 그런 논란이
>> 된 거 같아서
>> 네
>> 그이 부분에 대해서 어떻게
>> 뭐 맞는 말씀 드시고요
>> LT 지금 체결하는 거는 2분기
가격을 바탕으로 체결하는 거여서
여기서 체결하는 가격은 앞으로 3분기
4분기 내년 올라가는 것까지 다
반영을 못
>> 계약이에요. 가격은
기대치 대비 좀 하향 조정되는게 맞는
거고 그만큼은 물량은 좀 확정해
나가는 그런 상황인데 근데 LT보다
더 중요한 거는 LT를 요구하는
시장인가가 중요한 거죠. 사실
그런 좋은 시장에서는 LT 안 하는게
저 국기 입장에서 좋은데
>> 음
>> 요구하는데 안 해 주는게 사실 제
가장 베스트 케이스예요.
>> 음
>> 그죠? 어
>> 계속 에디 해 달라고
발목 잡고 있는데 아 우리는 가격
올라 그러니까 안 해 줄 거다. 이게
가서 베스트 케이스고 여기서 AT를
이제 일부 해 줄 수밖에 없는
거겠죠. 장기적인 이제 관계도
있으니까는.
어 그런데 이거를 이제 5년짜리 딱
계약해 버리면 5년 동안은 가격적인
이제 상승은 기대가 좀 없다고 봐야
될 거 같아요. 그만큼은 이제 뭐
매출 베이스는 깔아놓겠지만은 그래서
하방은 올라갈 거 같은데요.
>> 상방은 억제해야 되고 그 사이에
진폭은 왔다 갔다 할 거 같아. 그런
맥락이고. 근데 이거는 플레이어가
정해져 있어야 성립하는 맥락이에요.
그래서 제가 말씀드렸지만 중국
플레이어가 지금 올라고 있어요. 이런
중국 플레이어는 스팟로 다 뿌려
버리거든요.
>> 그럼 LTA가 그럼 만약 3년 후에
스팟 빠져 있으면은 새로 차결할 때
가격이 안 빠질까요?
>> 그것도 생각하죠. 영원한 LTA는
아니거든. 아,
>> 3년 후에 가격이 빠져 있으면 빠진
가격으로 다시 계약을 하고
>> 음
>> 그럼 결국에는
좀 지속 가격 지속 기간을 좀 늘릴
뿐이지 결국에는 시크리컬 영역이 조금
확정된 개념이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다.
>> 하긴 그 장사가 진짜 잘 되는 집
맨날 가면 항상 줄서야 되는 집은
예약 안 받잖아요. 예.요 앞에
화동관도 예약 안 받을 걸.
뭘 예약을 받아 사람들이 계속
찾아오면 되죠. 그죠? 약간 그런
개념으로 문부가 오히려 LTA를 안
하는게 오히려 나올 수도 있다. 계속
수요가 만약에
>> 줄선 상황에서요.
>> 뭐 계속 줄 있다면
>> 근데 엘론머스가 얼마 전만 하더라도
뭐 테라팩 짓겠다 뭐 이런 얘기를
하는 거 보면 앞으로 3년 동안은
계속 줄선다. 3년 동안 계속 출석고
그러면 가격을이
공급단 메모리 메이커들이 어떻게 보면
해계모니를지고 있는 상황이면 그죠.
뭐 굳이이 가격에 우리가 개조 예약
안 받아 이런 수도 있는 건데 그래서
저정하게 지금 LT 비중이 한 25%
아니에요. 지금 마이크로이 25%만큼
체결했다고 하고 50%까지 채울 만한
지금 잠재 계약이 있다이 정도 언급을
했고요. 나머지 업체들은 그걸 좀
따라가는 맥락으로 하고 있고 숫자로
얘기는 잘 안 하고
>> 저번에 그런데 얼마 전에 마이크론
실적 발표했잖아요. 마이크론
실적에서도 LT를 강조하면서
>> 어 시황에 대한 어
>> 이전의 그 패턴이 극복이 되고
있다라고 얘기를 했고요.
>> 맞네.이 이 그리고 어 그때 실적에서
그 매출 총익률이 그 당시 분기에
81%
>> 그다음 분기 86%인가 뭐 이렇게
제시를 했는데
>> 사람들이 깜짝 놀랐죠. 네. LTA
하면서도 이렇게 어 그 가격 전가력이
있다는 걸 생각을 하고 물론 이제 그
이후에는 어 이제부터는 그 매출
총익률 가이던스를 제시하는 거가
의미가 없다고 얘기를 했어요. 왜냐면
가격 자체가 여기에서 더 올라가기는
어렵고 그거로 인해서 매출 총익률이
더 개선될지는 절 모르겠다. 그렇지만
영업 이익률은 조금씩 더 어 개선될
거다라고 얘기를 했는데 제가 하고
싶은 말은 뭐냐면은 불과 한 달
차입니다. 그 마이크론 3 4
5고요.
>> 그 하이닉스 4 565입니다. 그 한
달 차이가 이렇게 큰 그가 그
컨센서스 차이를 맞는다. 이거는 조금
저는 이해하기 어렵습니다.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예.
맞습니다.
그래서 솔직히 저는 어떻게
생각하냐면이
LTA가 무조건 저는 긍정적이라고.
그리고이 LTA가 방금 최부사장
얘기처럼 지금 영업 이익률 겨우 5%
10% 나오는데 야이 가격에 5년
장기 계약 해 줘 이러면
>> 뭐 아이 업항이 안 좋으니까 겨우
5%짜리 5년 그래도 이거라도 우리가
하자. 음
>> 뭐 이런 상황이 아니라 지금 영업률
이번에 81%
>> 예
>> 뭐 지금 영업 이익률 81% 이런
상황에 3년 5년으로
장기 공급 계약을 맺고 있다는
거잖아.
>> 그래서 저는 100% 됐으면 좋겠어.
LT 비중이.
>> 그러면 어떻게 보면 이제 투자하는
입장에서는 되게 쉬워져요.
>> 네. 어 3년에서 5년에 앞으로의
캐시플로가
드스 됐다면 그다음부터는요
주가 진짜 PR만 갖고 매매하면 돼.
왜냐면 내년 내후년에이가 고정이 됐기
때문에 그죠.
>> 그러면 매매가 되게 쉬워져요. 오히려
빠지면 무조건 사면 되지.
>> 이익이 둔화될까 봐 주가가 빠지는
건데
>> 이익이 만약에 고정이다.
>> 음. 그러면
그러면 너무 투자하는게 있죠.
쉬워지죠. 그죠?
>> 그래서요 LTA에 대한 노이즈는 어
그 노이저가 뭘 얘기하는지는 알겠는데
영업 익률이 복지.이 영업 익률이
복지에서 왜 팔아야 된다냐면 이게
다운 사이클로 들어가서 영업이 익률이
이제 다시 쭉쭉쭉 빠지는
>> 그런 걸 두려워해서 하는 건데
>> 오히려 LT가 그걸
막아 주는 겁니다. 역할을 하니까.
그래서 이런 노이즈 속에서 최근에 두
개짜리 레버이 제가 좀 변동성을 좀
키웠다고 생각합니다.
그런 부분 때문에
아까 삼성전자가 지금 얼마 빠졌다고?
차트에 나오면 32%
>> 32% 파이닉스가 35%
>> 어 그 이제 가격적인 메리트는 다시
왔어요.
>> 음
>> 그리고 말씀드린 대로 이제 시장이
지금이 반도체 업항 전체에 어 보르무
회협이라든지 금리가 영향을 주고
있다. 부분에 보시고 안 그래도 밑에
보니까 하나 김도원 연구원이 약세장이
아니라 제 가격화다. 예. 요즘 방송
나와서 아주 어 강하게 얘기를 많이
그동안에 했던 걸로 알고 있는데 내용
한번 보겠습니다. 그래서 이번에
하락은
수급적인 요인으로 많이 빠졌다라는
의견인 건데요. 어 이번 조정은
약세상이 시작이라기보다 1차 상승
이후과 수급의 균형을 다시 찾아가는
재가격화야 과정에 가깝다라는
의견입니다. 외국인 매도와 국민연금
리밸런싱 개인 유동성 존나가 지수
회복을 지연시키고 있다라고 보고
있고요. 반도체 이익계 방향은 아직
꺾이지 않았다. 하이닉스 ADR은
한국 메모리 기업이 미국 시장에서
AI 인프라 자산으로 재평가받는 첫
시험때라고
보고 있고요. ADL 프리미엄과
메모리 유지가 된다면 이번 조정
강세장의 끝이 아니라 2차 상승을
준비하는 구간이 될 가능성이 높다.
여전히 주도주를 사라라는 전략은
유효하다라고 보고 있는데요. 한국
증시는 현재 중요한 분수령의 위치해
있다. 메타발 AI 수요 두 우려가
있고 이란을 둘러싼 지정학적 긴장
유가와 금리의 재상승 가능성이 동시에
하 할인율을 높이고 있다라고
하는데요. 외국인 자금 이탈이
이어지는 가운데 국민연금의 국내 주식
리밸런시 부담도 다시 부각이 되고
있고 개인 투사자는 조정 국면에서
매수에 나서곤 있지만 예탁금 감소는
추가 매수 여력이 약화되고 있음을
보여준다. 현재 시장의 핵심 변수는
이익이 아니라 수급이다라고 하고요.
아마 메타발 우려를 AI 수요 종류로
해석하는 것은 성급하다라고 보고
있는데 시장이 주목하기 시작한 것은
투자 규모가 아니라 투자 회수
속도라고 볼 수가 있겠고요. AI
인프라 투자가 감소한 것이 아니라
자본 효율성과 수익화에 대한 요구
수준이 높아지고 있는 상황이다.이는
수요 소멸이라기보다는 투자 평가
방식이 변화하는 과정으로 보는 것이
적절하다라는 의견입니다. 어 반도체
업항 역시 아직 정점을 논할 단계는
아니라고 보는데요. 어 시장 조사
기간에 따르면 26년 성률의 정점일
수 있겠지만 매출 가수의 정정은
아니다. 27년에는 성장률은
둔화되더라도 절대 시장 규모는 다시
확대될 것으로 보고 있고요.
성장률나와 업항 하강은 동일한 의미가
아니라고 볼 수가 있겠고이 같은
판단을 확인할 첫 시험대가
SK이닉스의 ADR 상장이라고
합니다. ADR 공무에는 약
17105억 달러의 주문이 올렸고
발행 규모 대비선 경쟁률은 일곱배를
기록을 했습니다. 공무가 역시 직전
서울 주가 환상 가격 대비 약
2.9% 높은 수준에서 결정이
됐고요. 일반적인 해외 증자가 할인
발행되는 것과 달리 SK하이닉스는
할증 발행에 성공을 했다.이는 미국
투자자들이 SK닉스를 단순한 메모리
사이클 주가 아니라 HBM 중심 AI
인화 자산으로 평가하기 시작했다는
의미로 해석을 할 수가 있겠다는
의견을 제시했습니다. 결국엔 이번에
시장이 빠진 건 뭐
이전에는
외국인 매도는 뭐 계속해서 있었고요.
국민연금은 매수, 개인 매수 이렇게
시장이 움직였는데 이번에는 외국인
매도는 유지가 되고 국민연금도 매도로
돌아섰고 그리고 심 개인들의 심리를
흔들 수 있는 이슈들이 나오면서
매수의 주체였던 개인들의 심리 악화로
인해서 시장이 지금 수급이 많이
빠져나가고 있다라고 하는데 이런
부분은 이제 정점을 지나서 어느 정도
완화가 된다면 다시 한번 하반기에
시장이 반등할 수 있는데이 부분을
우리가 한번 노려보자.
라는 의견을 제시했습니다. 결국에는
어 하나 김두원 연구원님도 반도체
쪽에 주가 상승이 아직 끝나지
않았다라는
걸 베이스로 깔고 이야기를 하고 있는
거거든요. 그런 부분을 이전에
리포트들도 몇 개 읽어 보니까 비슷한
의견을 계속 제시하고 있더라고요.
>> 언제 나온게 일이 보
>> 어제입니다. 어제 네
>> 어 ADR 공무화 얘기를 하고 있어
가지고 그 공무화 얘기는이 정도로
이제 살려난 사람들이 많다 요런
거죠. 네.
이제 공무 얘기는 어제 처음에도
얘기했지만 그 TSMC 케이스만
보더라도
지금 ADR의 가격 자체가 본주
가격으로
그 공목을 결정이 됐기 때문에 미국에
상장되면 15% 정도의 프리미엄을
받게 되기 때문에 본주 가격 대비해서
거래가
청약을 할 수 있다면 외국인은 해치
펀드나 이런 입장에서는 무조건 이제
매수를 하는게 맞았죠. 그렇게 매수를
해 놓고 어 본주에 대해서 숏을
때린다든지
본주에 대해서
비슷한 피어 그룹이 마이크로에 대해서
숏을 딱 때리면 100억 원치
신청하고 그럼 본주 대비 15%
붙으니까 무조건 15% 먹는 거죠.
거기에 대한 리스크였지는 어 본주에
대한 100억 원치 매도를 때려
놓는다 하면 돼 있는 거기 때문에
그래서 본주에 그 ADR에
저렇게 많이 몰렸다 하는 것 자체가
메모리 주식에 대한 수요가 아직까지도
되게 많다 요렇게 해석하는 건 좀
>> 아닌 거 같고
약세장 얘기냐 재격화 재격화이 말이
나는 이런 말은 처음 들어오는데
제가 해석 가기로는 너무나 단기적으로
급등한 부분에 대한 이격 조정을 이런
식으로 표현하신게 아닌가라는 생각.
>> 1차 상승 이후 가격
>> 수급이 균형을 다시 찾아가는 제각한
과정이 겁니다.
자, 알겠습니다.
자, 우리나라 시장은 어떻게
했습니까?
네. 저희 시장 -0.56%
하락해서 출발했고요. 현재
-1.92%로
하락폭금 더 키우고 있습니다. 네.
네.
그리고 코스닥은
>> 네. 코스닥 - 0.28%로 하락해서
출발했고 현재 -2.41%로
하락부터 키우고 있습니다.
>> 네. 아무래도 어제 장태 음목으로
맞다 보니까
반대 매매가 좀 나오겠죠. 나올
수밖에 없을 거예요.
>> 예. 어제도 제가 소통을 해 봤는데
담보부적자들
매도가 많이 나가고 있
>> 한 12시까지
정도는
어이 반대 매매가 좀 나오면서 조금
또 약간의 험악한 분위기가 10시나
10시가 12시까지 이어지고 오히려
우후장에서 좀 반등이 강하게 좀
일어나지 않을까 그런 생각이 들고
그동안에 이제 국민연금의 매도 얘기도
많았었잖아요. 근데 국민연금의 매도가
어 지난번 9,300 이렇게 갔을
때는 어 국내 주식 비중이 30%가
넘어갔기 때문에 그래서 뭐 5%를
반이 몇 퍼센트를 반이하면 뭐 50조
60조도 나올 수 있다. 뭐
그랬었는데이 정도 빠지면 이제 팔게
없어져.
>> 자동으로 비중조정 비중 조정이
되겠죠.
있다는 겁니다. 네.
>> 그렇죠. 그 만약에 그게 30%였는데
>> 시장이 지금 20% 이상 빠졌잖아요.
>> 그러면
20%만 빠져도 6%가 날라.
>> 예. 왜냐면 미국 시장은 가만히
있었거든요.
>> 그렇죠. 미국 시장이랑 다른 시장
가만히 있었기 때문에
>> 20%만 빠져도 6%면 24%가 되고
지금은 25% 빠졌으니까. 그러면
국민연금도 이제는 매도가 나오기보다는
다른 이제 기관들이 우리나라 기관들이
돈이 많습니다. 지금 뭐 국민연금뿐만
아니라 어 저희가 예전에 기관 자금을
운용화했을 때 각종 공제라든지
>> 많거든요.
>> 그런 각종 공제라든지 그리고 우리나라
이제 법인 자금도 되게 많죠.
>> 예.
>> 예. 법인 자금을 운용하시는 분들도
지금 되게 걱정이 많으실 거예요.
많으실 건데이
바닥이 어딘가라는 부분은 그래서 아까
6,300에서 9,300이든지
아니면 어 지금 6,700인데
이게 밑으로 더 떨어질 룸이 만약에
6,300이다. 6,700에서
6,300에 이제 400포인트 맞는
건데
>> 그러면 66 36 앞으로 빠져 봐야
6%예요. 빠져봐야 6%고
어 반등이 들어갔을 때 중간에 피부
포인트가 거의 한 7,800까지
반등이 들어가면 여기서 이제
1,000포인트 올라가면
1100 정도가 올라가면 거의 15%
이상 먹거든요.이 위험 대비 기대
승률이 이제 높아졌습니다.
지금 저희 회사에 이제 신규 자금을
받으면 여기서는 뭐 그냥 95% 정도
>> 어 나채워도 될 거 같아.
어제 워맨 신박 말씀드렸지만 최근에
이제 주직을 시작하신 분들은 이런
변동성이 아까 일반 지수의
MDD에서도 봐지지만 어 지금 보면
뭐 시장이 완전히 패닉이고
절망적인 상황 보이지만이 늘 있 늘
있는
그거는 변동성이다라고 보시면 되고
특히나 이제 짝수해 짝수해의 789
제가 그것도 미국 중간 중간 선거가
있는 해. 그 골프로 따지면 핸디캡
1번 홀이
미국의 중간 선거가 있는 3분. 예.
핸드캡 1번홀에 지나가고 있는
부분이고이 어려운 국면에서 주가가
저렇게 많이 빠지다 보니까 어 올해
연말부터 내년 장은 아주 좋을 수밖에
없고요. 저 주가들이 다 보는 할
거기 때문에
자동 관리를 좀 잘하고 계신 분들
입장에서는
굉장한 또 기회가 소래했다. 요렇게
해석하시면 될 것 같습니다. 예.
체슬리 모닝 브리프 오늘 7월 14일
순서는 여기까지
>> 지수의 지수의 치겠지
>> 지수 아 맞다 맞다. 예
>> 그러니까 시간이 남아서 뭐라
해치했는데
감사합니다.
자 어젯밤
어제오뱅
나스닥하고 필반 SP오하고 나스닥은
올라가고 필반은 조금 빠질 것 같다.
어 얘기하셨는데 필반은 빠졌고 좀
많이 빠졌고
>> 많이 빠졌습니다.
>> SM버그 나스닥은 뭐 호르무저가
저렇게 될 줄 뭐 어떻게 알았어
그죠? 음
>> 추천프로 오늘은 어떻게 될 거 같아?
오늘도 좀
빠질 것 같습니다.
>> 미국 시장은 왜
>> 일단 선물도 좀 빠지고 있고
소포기지만 빠져 있고 그
다음 주 실적 발표까지 좀 기다리는
자금들이 많을 것 같아서
>> 매수세가 많이 붙지는 못할 것 같어.
나스닥은 어떻게 될 거라?
>> 파락
>> 바람.
>> 네. 음.
>> 네. 추천 올라갈 거 같다. 뭐 요런
얘기 할 때 내가 어 주식 꽉 채우고
있구나. 내가 그랬잖아요.
>> 꽉 채우고 있다라고 대답했는데.
>> 주식 시간 얼마 됐지?
오늘
2018년 정도씩 해서 8년 정도.
>> 어, 그래도 오래했구나.
>> 네.
>> 8년 정도 해 보니까 이번 장은 어떤
거 같아요?
>> 롤러코스터 타는 느낌.
>> 어.
>> 많이 변동성이 심해 가지고
>> 신용만 안 하면 돼.
>> 음. 신용은 다행이 없을.
신용만 안으면 신용은
그 선수들이 하는 건데 아까 제가
날씨 얘기했잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그 날씨가 폭풍우가 몰아치고 하면 그
K2나 이런데 보면 한 번씩 보면
약점으로 돌아가시는 분들이 한 번씩
생기잖아요. 그죠?
그래서이 되게 조심해야 돼요.이 주식
시장은 항상 정말 K2나 에베레스트
이런 아주 험란한 산을 등반한다.
요런 느낌으로 투자를 하셔야 되지
조금만 교만하면 반드시 대가를 치르게
되고
>> 교만한 자의 무덤이라는
>> 신용도 습관 아닌가요? 신용도 습관
아
>> 안 쓰면 그게 우리가 마이너스
통장처럼 마통 절대 못 했어.
>> 그렇죠. 그것도 맞아요. 습관이라고
보면 되는데
>> 마통이어 사다가 한독 꽉 차면 더
이상 이제 못 쓰니까
>> 하지만 주식은 신용 잘못 쓰다가는
그냥 원금 다 날려 버리니까
레버리지나 그다음에 신용 이런 거는
정말 내가 선수가 됐다고 해도 한 번
더 생각을 해 봐야 돼.
>> 정말 내가 신용을 쓰는게 맞.
그렇지만 이런 조정장은 그냥 시간이
다 해결해주 지난지나 뭐 그렇게 오랜
시간이 걸리지도 않아. 뭐 하이닉스
삼성전다 플러스 아니 이게.
자, 그리고 어, 필반 오늘 어떻게
될 것 같습니다.
>> 전 상승인데요. 아까 말씀드렸듯이 그
올해 MDD 보시면 이제 -15%
구조적 하락이 아니면 -15%
정도에서는 반등이 나왔는데 오늘 또
중요한 트리거가 될 만한 CPI
발표가 있는데 제가 볼 때는 뭐
시장에서 조금 낮게 예상하곤 있지만
그거보다 뭐 한 0. 1% 포인트 뭐
플러스 마이너스를 나온다고 하더라도
크게 좌우가 되지 않을 것 같아요.
이미 주가가 뭐 너무 많이 빠져 있어
가지고. 그래서 그거는 그냥 참고하는
지표로 될 거 같고 호르몬저 해협
관련해서 뭐 이러저런 얘기들이
나오는데 아 트럼프 대통령 성향으로
봤을 때 지금 금리가 4.6%가
넘어가는 상황이고 주식 태권 다
약세로 만들려고 하진 않을 것
같거든요. 분명히 타코 비슷한 발언이
아 발언이 어 나올 거 같고 또
우리나라도 그렇지만 미국도 레버리지가
되게 많잖아요. 그 디레버리징
과정에서 일어나는 급격한 변동성에 한
가지라고 생각하는데 어느 정도 딜
레버리지가 좀 진행되는
꽤 진행됐다고 생각을 해 보면
지금부터는 조금 신규 자금 또는 저가
매수도 들어올 가능성이 있지 않을까?
특히 이제 어 최근 발표되는
그 증권사들의
해외 아비들의 이제 어 AI 관련된
어
데이터들을 보면은 계속 상향되고 있는
거 같거든요. 어, 케펙스도 그렇고
수요 쪽도 그렇고 그 빅테크들의
RPO 그 수주 장고도 그렇고 그래서
제가 볼 때는 이번에 그 디테크들
실적이 나오게 되면은
아까 뭐 커뮤니케이션한 7.2% 2%
전년동 대비 상승하는 거 있는데
그거보다 더 많이 나올 것 같아요.
그래서 전반적으로
메모리만 올라가던 시장에서 조금
확산이 되면서
종목별로 좀 차별화되는 시장이 되지
않을까? 그래서 아 지금부터는 좀
진짜 진검 승부가 되지 않을까
싶습니다.
>> 음.
>> 오늘 상승하러 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 좋은 말씀 같네.
>> 어, 우리 모닝 브리프 동자 수가
2,명이 넘어가면 바닥이다. 뭐 그런
얘기들 예전에 누구가 해 주셨는데
오늘 동접 자수가
>> 2,200명까지
>> 2,200까지 갔었기 때문에 거의
어, 이거 진짜 우리 모닝 브리프
동차수 이거 진짜 휴먼 인덱스 조는
된다고 봐요. 공포 지수잖아. 공포
지수. 그죠? 바닥 쳤다는 신호가
나온 거 같은데 저는 바닥 쳤다는
신호가 나온 거 같아.
>> 자, 오늘 코스피 코스닥은 어떻게
되지? 코스닥 먼저
>> 먼저 아 여전히 음봉으로 나왔어요.
>> 여전에 음봉.
>> 네.
>> 어제도 음봉이 없다. 그죠?
그리고 근데 어제 코스닥이 상승
초반에 좋게 시작하다가 워낙 이제
시장이 밀리면서 반대 매매가 나오게
되면 그 계좌 통으로 그냥 다 반대매
나오게 돼 있기 때문에
>> 영향을 좀 같이 받은 거 같아요.
>> 코스피는 어떻게 될 것
>> 최근에 뭐 거의 맞춘 적은 없는 거
같은데 계속 틀리고 있는데요.
>> 네.
오늘 딱 지금 보니까 120일선 찍고
코스피가 올라오는 모습이 나타나고
있는데 또 이런 거 보고서 어 찍고
반등했으니까 오늘 양봉이겠다 하고
이런 식으로 양봉을 치면 또 뚫고
내려가고 이랬거든요. 그렇게 5일선과
20일선과 60일선을 다 깨고 내려
>> 상황인데
>> 어제 그리고 최근 흐름 특히 오늘
보면 개인 투자자분들의
투매가 나오고 있거든요. NX장에서
엄청나게 파시더라고요. 개인자분들이.
어, 이제는 못 견디겠다라고 파는
느낌이 좀 드는데
원래 그런 구간이 마음 아프지만
바닥인 경우가 좀 많았던
거 같아서
오늘 뭐 10시에 트럼프 연설도 좀
있고 또 CPI 이런 것들이 있긴
한데
양봉날 가능성이 좀 높다라는 생각에
배팅해 보겠습니다. 양보.
>> 어, 양보.
>> 네. 네.
>> 예. 네.
>> 어제까지 6일 연속 음봉이었네요.
네.
>> 6일 연속 음봉이었고 오늘 보니까
저기 어 저기 120일선이죠?
>> 네.
>> 예. 120일선에 딱 터치 딱
터치했네. 보니까
120일선 저기서는 일단은 뭐
물리더라도 매수 대응해야지 뭐
여기서는 그동안에이 선에서는 항산
반등이 들어왔었으니까
그런데이 전쟁대처럼 또 한 2주
반등다가
>> 음
>> 또 한 번 더 그죠.
>> 그렇네. 그게 아마 창시 메모리 상장
전후 해 가지고 쌍바닥 패턴 한번
만들고 그러고 올라가지 않을까 하긴
생각하기 때문에 어 아 나 지금
휴가가 있는데 아니면 다 다음 주
이번 주 주말부터 놀러 가야 되는데
아 이걸 주식을 사고 가야 되나
말아야 되나 하는 분들은 그냥 또
2주 3주 정도 놀고 와서 주식
사셔도 돼요.
>> 예.
창신 메모리 진짜 궁금하더라고요.
왜냐면 지금 시장에서 어 예상 시가
총액이 몇백초에서 몇 천까지 왔다
갔다 합니다. 레인지가한테
>> 물어보면 되지. 님 몇백조
>> 몇백조 예상조 원
>> 몇백조 원 우리나라 돈으로 한
800조
>> 예
>> 얼마 저거 시청
>> 시작하자마자는 지금 그 작년 마크충
하면 아니고 작년 마켓 중하면은 3초
그 100조로 정도 되는데요 작년
말키 중 하면 지금 시장 기대하는
거는 대충는 2조부터 5조까지 갈 수
있어요. 2조로 하면은 거의 400조
정도 되고
>> 450조 정도네
>> 맞아요. 조관을 가면은 청조네
>> 청조하고 왜냐면 요통수 5% 바이
없어요. 정말 잘 돌아가는 그 낙업
거리는 사람이 있어요. 그 초기적으로
요청 25% 없으니까. 음.
>> 그래서 이거를 잘 못하면은 아마
2천조가 갈 수 있어요. 수급 때문에
맞아요. 충분히 가능성이 있다고
생각해요.
>> 왜냐면 지금 해외로 보면은
>> 메모리 업체 피하는 다 거의 뭐 네배
다섯 배존차잖아요.
>> 충구 반도체 전체
>> 그 빨리가
>> 보통은 40배 50에 받은 회사예요.
뭐 그 SMS 이런 회사는 또 거의
뭐 60배 70배 받은 회사예요.
근데 50회 곱하기 내년은 예상치로
계산하면은 대충는 10조 나올 수
있어요.
10조 위야.
>> 네. 10조 위야. 그러면 2천조
50에 곱하 이렇게 나올 수조
>> 그거 공모 참여 못 하죠.
>> 아 우리요
>> 못.네
무 못합니다.네
물어프니까 좀 뭐 받아서도 뭐 받지
못해.네
>> 할 해도 뭐 받을 수 없지.
먼저 충분 내 기관 대상으로 먼저
하고 나머지 부분은 뭐 지피 먹는 큰
소리사 장기적으로 막 거리고 그런
식으로 할 수 있고
>> 어
>> 외국인한테 주는 물량이 한 몇 %
되는지
>> 그거는 거의 없다고네
맞아요.
>> 공무가는 대충
>> 공무가는 대충은 내일 정도 오늘 내일
정도 나올 수요 어제는 내부적으로
다청했어요. 대회적으로 공개할 때는
그 오늘 아니면 내일 그 상장은
27일네
>> 그럼 한 8 한 한 600조에서 한
800조 정도로 상장하려나
>> 문화하게 아마 대충 그 수인 거 같아
맞아요 그 정도 왜냐면 처음에는
상한가 한가 없어요
>> 그 수급 때문에 그래서 한 번에 아마
500% 뭐 다섯 배 정도 알 수도
있어요.
>> 왜냐면 그 이런 크잖아 이렇게 되면은
ETF 추정치 추정하는 ETF 다
사야 돼요.
수급을 물리면네
>> 이렇게 오라 할 수가
>> 다만 그 가급대 참
>> 어느 가격 때 뭐 그 우조 넘어가면네
사이 이유가 진짜 없어요.
>> 5조 넘어가면 천조 넘어가는 건가?
>> 5조 넘어가면 5조는 거의조 넘는
거잖아. 맞아요.
>> 나는 천조 미만이면 무조건 질려야
된다 생각했어.
>> 그 지금 매니저들이 다 그렇게
생각하고 있어요. 우전 미만 하면은
무조건 사고 우전 넘어가면은 좀 상황
좀 부고. 5조 넘어가도 나는
1200조
1200조 밑에서 사야 되네요.
>> 수급되는 시
>> 이번에 그 CAT에 대해서도 봤지만
중국은 중국 내수 메모리 수요가
얼마나 많
>> 얼마나 많은데 중국 정부가 우리가
미국 정부 미국 기업에 대해서도
프리미엄이 붙어서 거래되잖아요.
마이크로 프리미엄을이
뭘 하이닉스가 미국에 상장되기 때문에
마이크론 멀티플을 따라간다. 저는
말도 안 되는 소리라고 생각해요.
미국 정부가 지켜주는 기업 아니라
>> 우리나라 기업이라 그렇죠.
문 명이 있어야 되는 거고
>> 그러면 창시 메모리도 똑같아요. 중국
정부가 지켜주고 중국 정부가 창신껏
서
>> 어 그런 식으로 창신거 우선서 이런
>> 분위기일 건데 SMIC도
그렇잖아요.네
>> 제가 걱정하는 부분은이 호산은 이렇게
가지고 갈 수 있는데 이게 실적 되게
안축하게 나올 수 있어요. 왜냐면
공교적으로 캡스 투자하고 이렇게
하면은 강감한 상관이 되게 많이 나올
수 있어요. 다른 돈을 다 해야 될
거예요. 그리고이 회사는 만들셨기
전에 만들기 전에 돈 벌고 싶어서 번
만는 회사 아니에요. 이거 이거 이거
정체적으로 만이 구추이 스 만들어서
뭐 이거 하고 싶어서 만들었어요. 돈
벌고 싶어서 만든 회사 아니에요.
>> 그래서 돈 계속서야 돼요. 이쪽으로
>> 그러겠지.
근데 결국은 중국 메모리 반도체
시장에 그 큰 캡티브 마켓을 갖고
있기 때문에 그래서 어 멀티플이 좀
높게 거래될 거다라고 생각을
>> 그런 생각을 저도 하고 있기 때문에
어 상신 메모리에 더가도 지난번에
스페이스엑스 상정한다고 일시적으로
돈이 몰리면서 시장이 한번 출렁거렸던
것처럼
>> 창시 메모리 상장이 메모리 반도체
체의요 어파요 주식에는
>> 일시적으로 분명히 영향을 좀 주는
거고
끝나고 상정이 되고 상장되고 나서 한
2주 정도는 돼야 제대로 이제
>> 가격이 형성된다라고 보면
>> 음음
>> 그 정도 되면 이래저래
이번 메모리 반도체의 주가 조정도
거의 이제 끝나지 않을까?
그러고 나서이 3분기 실적 시전으로
들어가는 9월 10월 정도 되면
>> 가파르게 반등이 들어오면서 모건
스탠리의
리포트가 항상 그 선빵을 좀 빨리
때린다 했잖아요.
>> 예. 선빵을 빨리 좀 때리는데 실적이
계속 밀고 올라오기 때문에
>> 항상 오른쪽을 만들어 준다. 그런
말씀을
드렸듯이
조금 어이 투자에서 물리신 분들은
결국 시간이 해결해 주는데 한 3개월
정도 나오죠.
예, 오늘 최선님 오니 브리프는 예,
여기까지 하도록 하겠습니다. 더운
날씨가 지속되고 있으니까 건강도
유의하시고 계좌 관리도 잘 하시기
바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.